WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
FOR MAY FOURTEENTH HEARING. A
COUPLE OF ITEMS THAT THEY NEED
TO GO THROUGH- PROCEDURAL OF.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD SOME OF THIS
BEFORE AND IF YOU HAVE THIS IS
NOT INTENDED FOR YOU AND IF YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN. A PLEASE LISTEN
CAREFULLY- TO STARTED LIKE TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF THAT HAVE
MADE OUR RETURN TO THE CAPITAL
HERE THE BILL'S PASSABLE. WILL
NOT SHARE A FEW NOTES ABOUT THE
LOGISTICS OF OUR HERE TODAY
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
IS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY AND TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. DUE TO THE CURRENT
STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PARTICIPATING PHYSICALLY
DISTANCING. ORDERS HERE. IN
YOUR ROOM AND DROP CAPITOL
BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
PERSON- WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE- IF YOU DO. OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES. ONLY TODAY. AND
WE'LL GO THROUGH THOSE IN JUST
A FEW. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PRESENT IN OUR HEARING
AND USE IN THE CHAMERS WERE.
HAVING PHYSICAL DISTANCING- AS
YOU CAN SEE THE SIGNS ON THE
SEATS. IN THIS SPACE WE GONNA
COMING FOURTEEN MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN THE
SIXTY. FACE THERE ARE STRUCK
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PRODUCT FOR
THE PUBLIC TO AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL ONE FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY IN THE HEARING- ITSELF
THE MEMBER OF THE BREAK IN THE
ROOM OR THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY BILL I LAST POSTED. AT
THE TIME THAT PUBLIC NOT
TOUCHED MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING TO RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVER OF PHYSICAL DISTINGUIR
LEAVING CAPITAL. IN THE LA. I
USE- ONE PERSON AT A TIME IS
THE RULE. FOR WITNESS- VIDEO
CONFERENCING IN THE ROOM. I
WERE ASKING IN ADDITION TO
BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. THAT
WE HAVE SOME BILLS SAYS MAKING
USE OF ONE OF OUR VEHICLE
ROOMS. LOCATED HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITNESSES WILL APPEAR
ON THE AND- SO IMMERSED WATCH
THEIR TEN. LOOK ON THE OUTSIDE
HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITNESSES.
ONCE WE GET INTO THAT PHASE OF
THE DISCUSSION. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHT DELAY FOR THE STREAM FOR
WITNESSES VIDEO CARD IN ROOM SO
PLEASE. PATIENT FOR PHONE
WITNESS SO WILL ALSO BE USING
THE MODERATOR TELEPHONE SERVICE
TO WHICH ANYONE CAN TESTIFY ON
THE BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THE HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN AGAIN THE NUMBER IS
877-692-8957. AND THE ACCESS IS
TO. THREE SEVEN YOU WILL FIND
HIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON THE TV SCREEN. PLEASE CALL
WHEN THE AUTHOR BILL OF THE
BILL YOU PLAN TO TESTIFY ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR PRESENTATION.
OKAY REMINDS YOU OF THAT GET
INTO EVERY ITEM ON THE AGENDA
PLEASE DO NOT CALL AHEAD OF
TIME. THE OPERATOR ILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS. PLACE IN THE
QUEUE BASED ON WHAT FOUR OR
OPPOSE IT BUILDING IF YOU ARE.
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL THE
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVE BROADCAST AND
YOU'RE SMART TO ASSIST TO
REDUCE SOUND ISSUES. SO BE
ADVISED IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDE. NEW OR AGAINST
THE BILL YOU WILL REMAIN ON THE
LIVE LINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED.
TO SPEAK. YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN ALSO
CALL COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2096
THE TWENTY STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP YOU. AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE I. ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT W ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WITNESS
TIME LIMIT FOR EACH BILL THERE
CAN BE UP TO TWO MAIN WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT AND TO ME WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. THESE WITNESSES
HAVE BEEN MADE KNOWN TO
COMMITTEE IN ADVANCE OF THE
HEARING EACH WITNESS WILL HAVE.
UP TO TWO MINUTES TO SPEAK I
WILL I HAVE THE NAMES OF THOSE
WITNESSES AND SO I WILL- CALL
YOUR NAME OUT WHEN WE'RE
GETTING READY TO. HAVE YOU
TESTIFIED. THANK YOU- FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTAIN SIR THE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA. ALSO BEING
MINE FOR RESPECT FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL FACE.
MEMBERS WE WOULD LIKE THAT TO
YOU FIVE TO RESPOND AS WE CALL
YOUR NAME FOR ROLL CALL- OR
PROVIDE COMMENT YOU'LL NEED TO
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE SO STAFF
CAN ACTIVATE WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK OUT. PLEASE
STAND. FACED A MICROPHONE WELL
BEGIN TO ENSURE YOUR VOICES ARE
WILL AND CAN BE RECORDED. YOUR
PRESENT A BILL TO THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE PRESENT THE- FROM THE
MICROPHONE- FOR THE BACK OF THE
ROOM I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
MISTER FLORA. WHO IS THE- WE'RE
NOT GOING TO SO AT THIS TIME
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE MISTER
SECRETARY IF YOU WILL PLEASE-
CALL THE ROLL- SO THAT WE MAY
ESTABLISH A QUORUM FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WHICH SECTOR. EDUARDO
GARCIA RESIDENCE AND WATER SEE
A PRESENT DALLY. DELHI
PRESIDENT BIGELOW. BIGELOW
PRESENT FLORA FLORA PRESENT
CHIU. CHIU PRESENT FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN PRESENT CRISTINA
GARCIA. GLORIA GLORIA PRESENT
KALRA. KALRA PRESENT LEVINE.
LEVINE PRESIDENT MATHIS. MATHIS
PRESENT RUBIO RUBIO PRESENT
SALAS SALAS PRESENT WOULD. WE
HAVE A QUORUM MISTER. AT THIS
TIME I'M GOING TO ASK THAT WE
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
BIGELOW SECOND BY MISS RUBIO.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
A. B. NINETEEN FORTY NINE AB
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AB TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX WITH AMENDMENTS AB
252-318-2570 FOUR. AB
302-218-3220 SIX AND EIGHTEEN
THIRTY TO. FIFTY TRIPS SAYING
THAT THERE'S A MOTION AND A SET.
NO QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS WHILE THE- THIRD CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA HI. DELHI
DELHI I BIGELOW BIGELOW I FLORA.
FLORA I CHIU CHIU I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GLORIA GLORIA I KALRA KALRA I
LEVINE LEVINE I MATHIS MATHIS
HI BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO HI
SALAS. SALAS I WOULD. THE VOTE
IS. TWELVE TWO ZERO. THANK YOU
MISTER SECRETARY WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON AT THIS TIME I AM ASKING
THAT WE TAKE ON ITEM TO A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT SOME
REMEMBER COOPER BILL WE
UNDERSTAND THAT MR MCCARTY IS
PRESENT. FOR MR COOPER AT THIS
TIME ASKING IF YOU PLEASE
THEREFORE. IS SUPPORT WITNESSES
ARE KEVIN TEAM. RECLAMATION
DISTRICT. WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING FIVE MISTER CARTY IS
IN HERE. MISTER COOPER THEN WE
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM FIVE. ITEM
FIVE IS AB TWENTY ONE. ZERO SIX
AGUIAR-CURRY. WILDLIFE HABITAT
NESTING BIRD HABITAT INCENTIVE
PROGRAM. AGUIAR-CURRY. YOU HAVE.
ITEM BY ONE OF OUR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WHICH IS ITEM SIX.
ITEM SIX IS BY DOCTOR WOULD.
THE WORD IS NOT IN THE HOUSE.
THAT IS CONSERVATION PROJECTS
CRACKHEAD VANCE PAYMENTS. WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAS A BILL THAT
IS ITEM NUMBER OF NINE. AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO SALAS
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
MULTI BENEFIT LAND. CON
CONVERSION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
MISTER SALAS IF YOU'RE READY
PLEASE PRESENT YOUR WITNESSES
WILL BE PABLO GARZA BERMEL
pDEFENSE FUND THAT TESTIFYING IN
MERION WATERMAN FROM THE REAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES SO WE
ASK THEM TO GET READY WE ASK
THE MISTER MOM TO A GET THAT
READY AS WELL. I THANK THE
CHAIR MEMBERS OF PRESENTS
ASSEMBLY TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO
TO THE COMMITTEE SEVERAL
RESEARCH INTO MANY IS IMPACTS
BY CREATING AN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THAT HELPS FARMERS
TRANSITION THEIR LAN MUST WATER
OF USES LIKE. A LAND FARMING
PROBLEM CHARGE RANGE OF CATTLE
RIGHT. SPRING FLOOD. AT THE
BORDER WITH THE UP WOULD HAVE
OF WHAT. DAVIS ANIMALS VOTER.
COMMUNITIES ARE SO ASK FROM
ABOUT. THANK YOU. THE WITH THE
MOST AND FLORES. MISTER YOU
HAVE TO WITNESSES WHO WILL BE
AND MISTER MODERATOR. YEAH I'M
HERE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU WE
HAVE- I'M SORRY WE HAVE PUBLIC
GAZA. WITH THE VERMONT DEFENSE
FUND WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING FOR
TWO MINUTES. HE'S HERE IN
PERSON. UNTIL LAST CAN TO DO IS
TWO MINUTE PRESENTATION. GOOD
MORNING THIS CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
MY NAME'S PUBLIC GARCIA WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY ON AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY TWO AT THIS TIME AND
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS FOR ALTERING THE BILL.
AND PRIORITIZING THE SUIT YOU
DURING THIS- OKAY IT'S PROBABLY
RECOGNIZE THE- THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT. IS
NECESSARY FOR LONGTIME
VIABILITY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
ECONOMY FARMS AND RANCHES IN
ENVIRONMENTS. BUT NO ONE SAID A
CHEATING THE GOALS OF THE AT
CIGNA IS. WILL BE EASY. AND IT
WILL COME WITH SIGNIFICANT
DESTRUCTION IN DIFFERENT
REGIONS OF THE STATE. IN FACT
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA ESTIMATES THAT
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES MAY COME OUT OF
PRODUCTION OF THE NEXT TWO TO
THREE DECADES. AND HOW LOCAL
DECISION MAKERS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. DEAL WITH THIS
DESTRUCTION. CAN HAVE. YOUTH
SIGNIFICANT IMPLICATIONS FOR
THESE REASONS WE CAN TURN THOSE
LINES INTO LETTERS LINE'S
BECOME A LIABILITY OR TURN THEM
INTO AN ASSET. AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY TWO WILL HELP US TAKE A-
THE LATTER PATH OF TURNING
THOSE LINES IN THE ASSET BUT
PROVIDING INCENTIVES. AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
IDENTIFIED FOR. IN THE
CHARACTERIZATION GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE. BUT PROTECTION OR TWO
OR MORE THOSE BENEFITS. THE
PROGRAM IS VOLUNTARY. AND WE
BELIEVE IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR
THE STATE TO PLAY A ROLE IN
ASSISTING LOCAL AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS IN ACHIEVING THE
GEAR- MITIGATING THIS
DESTRUCTION EVEN THE GOALS OF
CIGNA AND WE RESPECT WE ASK FOR
YOUR RIVALS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER GARZA WE HAVE-
SOMEONE TESTIFYING OVER THE
TELEPHONE AND THAT'S MERRY AND
WARMER THAN FROM THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. MISTER MODERATOR.
BUT YOU CAN'T MARIANNE RANDOM.
FORMER DALY EGGMAN HERE. YES
THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING CARA
GUARDS THAT AND ASK- TIA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY
NAME IS MERION WARMER GAMMON
AND BUYING ON BEHALF OF THE
REAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES THE
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THIRTY
SEVEN THE STATE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
MISTER THOMAS'S BILL TWENTY SIX
FORTY TWO THIS MORNING- YES
MEASURE PROVIDE ANOTHER TOOL IN
THE TOOLBOX FOR HOW WE THINK OF
THE LAND USE CHANGES THAT WILL
BE. PRECIPITATED BUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AND SCALABILITY
PLANS UNDER SIX MONTHS AN RC RC
IS COMMITTED EXCEPT FOR
IMPLEMENTATION THE CIGNA ARE
NUMBER COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
ACTIVE IN THEIR LOCAL GFAP.
TEST I WOULD INSURE THAT THE
NEEDS THE- IS. DEPENDENT GROUND
WATER ARE AT. WELL LIMóN THE
DAM DONE TO THE FOR AND RANCHES
AND THE ECONOMIES THAT ARE
COUNTIES DEPEND ON. AS NOTED BY
MISTER GARZA- VARIOUS SOURCES
OF ESTIMATED UP TO A MILLION
ACRES MAY COME ON AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION OVER THE NEXT THREE
GAMES. AND WITH THAT COMES A
CONCERN THAT WE THERE WERE
THOSE PLANS APPROPRIATELY.
ABOUT FAKE DO BECOME THAT
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE COMMUNITY
AND TO THE LANDSCAPE. COUNTIES
WITH THEIR LAND USE AUTHORITY
AND RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF GENERAL PLANS
HAVE A KEY ROLE IN HOW THOSE
CHANGES ON THE LANDSCAPE CAN BE
AFFECTED. SAMPLE WE CAN
IDENTIFY THOSE PLANS. THAT ARE
MOST APPROPRIATELY STEWARDED
FOR LONG TERM GOOD PRODUCTION
WHICH LANDS MIGHT BESTER
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE ECOSYSTEMS
AND HABITAT. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT AB TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO BY
CREATING A MULTI BENEFIT LAND
CONVERSION INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
WILL INSIST LANDOWNERS WATER
AGENCIES AND COUNTIES WITH
ANOTHER TOOL TO ASSESS THE
SPECTRUM OF OPTIONS AS THEY
MOVE FORWARD FROM INTENSIVELY
IRRIGATED KERMIT CROP. FIELD
CROPS THE BALLOT LANDS
PROVIDING ECOSYSTEM BENEFIT.
ALLOWING FOR THIS RANGE OF
CONSIDERATION WELL ALLOW THE
CAN THE COMMUNITY CHOICES NAY
TO MINIMIZE LOTS OF LOTS OF
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES WHICH
WORK WHICH ARE A CRITICAL PART
OF THE COUNTY GENERAL FUND. ON
ETHNIC TO GUARD THE NOTE IN
THIS PROGRAM IS BOND HEARING
AND WE BELIEVE IN IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE ADDITION TO THE
LANDSCAPE OF OPTIONS. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THOSE ARE TWO WITNESSES- BEEN
DESIGNATED IN SUPPORT. THIS
TIME I'M ASKING IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. WHO OULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE- THAT WOULD BE
THAT THAT WILL BE FOLLOWED BY.
THE SUPPORT- OVER THE PHONE SO
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU CAN GET
THOSE READY ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SUPPORT. A. B. TWO
SIX FOUR TWO. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. FIFTEEN NO ONE IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT OF MR
MODERATOR- DO YOU HAVE- IT ANY
ANY INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO
SUPPORT- THIS MEASURE OVER THE
PHONE. DO ENOUGH THERE ARE
OTHERS THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
STATE THEIR SUPPORT ME PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO HELLO FIRST
ONLINE NINETEEN WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND THOSE WHO WILL BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
PHONE NINE. ORGANIZATION AND I
POSITION. HI THIS IS ONE OF
THEM WE DON'T KNOW WHAT AUTUMN
ON CALIFORNIA WHAT IS MEASURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHERS IN Q.
MISTER CHAIR ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU. OVER THE LINE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR FIVE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS REBECCA
MARQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR LINE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS NATALIE
MAC THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN THE COALITION
SUPPORT. THANK HERE WILL GO TO
LINE FORTY SIX FOUR SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO THIS IS
MARK SMITH POLICY GROUP
TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. NEXT TIME MISTER CHAIR
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR A WE WILL- ANNOUNCED
THAT THE LEASE HERE WE HAVE NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION-
WITNESSES. AND IT'S ALL MOVE ON
TO ASKING IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO. BALCONY
ON THE FLOOR SEE NO ONE WHICH
MODERATE ON I ASK IF THERE ARE
ANY INDIVIDUALS ON HE PHONE
LINE- THAT HAVE- REGISTERED TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY TWO. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WHEN IN Q. AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU SIR. WITH
THAT- MISTER SALAS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE BY THE RESTAURANT
I THINK WITH THIS BILL WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS A BROAD
COALITION NOT ONLY FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND FARMING
GROUPS BUT EVEN THE ROLE
COUNTIES- AS YOU STATED THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE A-
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SKIP. AND BYPASS THE
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. EDUARDO GARCIA
BY EDUARDO GARCIA HI MEGHAN
DALLY. MEGHAN DELI I BIGELOW
BIGELOW I FLORA FLORA I. TO
CHIU I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
AUSTIN A GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I GLORIA GLORIA I KALRA KALRA
HI LEVINE. LEVINE I MATHIS
MATHIS I BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I WOULD.
WOOD I. THE VOTERS FOURTEEN
ZERO MISTER CHAIR THE VOTE THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THIS BILL
WILL MOVE ON TO OPERATIONS I
WILL GO ON TO. I DON'T FIVE WE
HAVE OUR PUBLIC ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CITY AGUIAR-CURRY AB TWENTY ONE
OH SIX. I WILL ASK MR MODERATOR
THAT THE THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO
BE CALLING IN. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR AGAINST THE MEASURE
BEGIN TO CALL IN. SO AT THIS
TIME FOR YOURS SON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH ME AND MY
OFFICE ON THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL. AB TWENTY ONE OH
SIX GENERATES FUNDING FOR THE
EXISTING NESTING BIRD HABITAT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. TO ENCOURAGE
FARMERS AND LANDOWNERS TO
CULTIVATE COVER CROPS ON I
DON'T PLANS TO PROVIDE WATER
FELT AND UPLAND GAME BIRDS WITH
WILDLIFE HABITAT. THE MEASURE
ADOPT A FIVE DOLLARS SURCHARGE
ON THE STATE DUCK AND UPLAND
GAME BIRDS STAMPS REQUIRED TO
HUG OF THE WATER FELL AND
UPLAND GAME BIRDS. AB TWENTY
ONE OH SIX ALSO REQUIRES
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY OVER THE
SPENDING OF FUNDS COLLECTED VIA
THE UPLAND GAME BIRD STAND. IN
LINE WITH CURRENT PRACTICE THE
STATE TAX STAMPS. THE NESTING
BIRD PROGRAM IS FLEXIBLE ENOUGH
TO BE CALIFORNIA'S GROWERS
NEED. A FUNDS CAN BE USED TO
PLANT COVER CROPS ENHANCE
EXISTING NESTING BIRD HABITAT.
ORDER ESTABLISHED NESTING COVER
ON LANDS THAT ARE FOLLOWED
UNDER DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX IS A RESOURCE
OF GENERATING CONSERVATION
MEASURE. THAT WILL COMPLEMENT
OUR STATE WIDE GOALS OF CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY THE PROTECTION OF OUR
WATER FELL SPECIES. THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION AND
ENJOYS WIDESPREAD SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR FIVE
YEAR VOTE. THANK YOU. SOME
REMEMBER WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ONE TESTIFYING
REPORT TESTIFYING VIA VIA VIDEO
CONFERENCE MARC HEADLEY
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL.
ASSOCIATION AND BUILD GAINES
WHO WILL BE- TESTIFYING. IN
SUPPORT. SOPA THEY ARE READY
PLEASE PERFECT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ARE KEN LAY ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
AS WELL AS THE GRASS AND WATER
DISTRICT IN THE NOR CAL GUYS
SPORTSMAN'S ASSOCIATION WE URGE
A YOUR STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE OF SIX WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE NECESSARY START UP
FUNDING FOR THE NESTING BIRD.
HABITAT INCENTIVE PROGRAM. THE
BILL- BUILDS ON THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL NON REGULATORY
APPROACH OF OTHER BURKE
CONSERVATION INITIATIVES SUCH
AS THOSE PROVIDED. THROUGH THE
FEDERAL FARM BILL- THE FEDERAL
DUCK STAMP ACT AND THE NORTH
AMERICAN WETLANDS CONSERVATION
ACT- IN THESE PROVIDE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES AND WORK
COOPERATIVELY WITH PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS. THERE IS A PRESSING
NEED FOR THE NESTING BIRD
HABITAT SENATE PROGRAM.
FORGETTING THAT OFF THE GROUND-
IT'S ALREADY AUTHORIZED AND SIT
IN THE FISHING GAME CODE. BUT
WE HAVE LACK OF SUFFICIENT
NESTING COVER ESPECIALLY IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS LIKE THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY- THAT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITING-
BREEDING HABITAT FOR WATERFOWL
PHEASANTS ANOTHER GROUND
NESTING BIRDS THIS IS BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY JOINT VENTURE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN. WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IS A SIGNATORY TO. SO THE
STATUS WILL NOT AS THE NEED FOR
THIS- AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX THEN
WOULD BASICALLY PROVIDE A FIVE
DOLLARS SURCHARGE ON STATE
DOCKS STAMPS AND- UPLAND GAME
BIRD STAMPS EACH OF WHICH ARE
REQUIRED TO HUNT. GAME BIRDS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS WOULD GENERATE
OVER ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE PROGRAM IT WILL. PROVIDE
CRITICAL START UP FUNDING THE
PROGRAM WOULD BE ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WHICH HAS THE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE TO- DELIVER
PRIVATE LAND WILDLIFE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS OUT ON THE LANDSCAPE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WHEN THE
FEDERAL DUCK STAMP- PRICE WAS
INCREASED IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IT BY TEN DOLLARS IN
ORDER TO. PROTECT BREEDING
HABITAT UP IN CANADA AND PARTS
OF THE PRAIRIE POTHOLE REGION-
THERE WAS NOCORRESPONDING DROP
IN FEDERAL DUCK STAMP REVENUES
AND SALES- THERE WAS ALSO A TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN STUDY BY THE
WISCONSIN DEPARTMENT OF NATURAL
RESOURCES THAT FOUND THAT
HUNTING LICENSE SALES. TEND TO
BE IN A LAST TECH THAT IS MY
INCREASE ISN'T PRICED LEAD TO
NET INCREASES IN REVENUE. NOW
WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY FOR INTRODUCING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALASKA THE NEXT WITNESS. TWO
MINUTES. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL GAME
PLEASE YES MORNING THIS
RESEARCH CONSERVATION DISTRICT
OR GRAYSON TO SOCIAIS A
CALIFORNIA DEAR ASSOCIATE AND
THE NOW WILD TURKEY. AB TWO
SIX. GAVE MANY MANY MORE
SPECIES WILL BE FROM THE BILLS
WERE ACCORDING. SMALL MAMMALS
BIRDS OF PREY OF THE NUMEROUS
IN SIX SPECIES SO WAS YEARS
SEVERAL FOR OF EIGHTY. SIX ASK
WINNERS OF A HUNDRED FROM THE
PROGRAM. FOR IN THE LAST GAME
EXCELLENT INDICATOR SPECIES WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE SINCE
AND HAPPY MEMBERS WE ARE ALSO
HAPPY OTHER BIRDS AND MAMMALS.
AND THE WOODS AND THEN SPEAKER
WORKING FOR STATE. WHAT WAS THE
MISSING AN. YES INTERNIST WE
LINK THE HAMMOCK CHAIN ORDER
REFER. CANADA WE ASKING WE'RE
IN THE WINTER OR STATE IN
CALIFORNIA NATION TO THOSE BE
ARE AT OR NEAR THEIR. NOW
THERE'S A LOT BIRD WHICH NO HI
IF I CAN DO ASK YOU IF YOU CAN
SEE THE- DIRECTLY INTO THE MIKE
WE COULD THE JUST HEARING THANK
YOU. MALLARD WHICH NESTING.
ALSO WIENER. RELATIONS AND ARE
DOWN 43% IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS ALL WHEN IT COMES TO
BUSINESS AND SAGE. SIX WHAT
ADDRESSING CONCERNS INCIDENTS
WHERE INTRUDERS DO YOU DO GOOD
THINGS. I MEAN THE OFFICE
LEAVING GOOD DIGITIZATION
STANDING AND ALSO ENCOURAGE TO
DELAY HEARTLESS OR BENEFICIAL.
AFTER THE NESTING SEASON
FURTHER ANYWAY OF SIX ONE.
ISSUE I DO USE IT WITH FUNDING
TO DO. THINGS FOR AT. LIKE
WAREHOUSES WHERE. AB SIX THE
DEAL JUST NEEDED COW NOT ONLY
FOR GAME BIRD GAME SPEECH BUT
ALSO FOR NOVEMBER BE SHE AS
WHERE THEY WERE. HEARD THANK.
THANK YOU. THAT THE- IT DOESN'T.
WE ARE NOW ALLOW IF THERE IS AN
IN THE ROOM. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK THEY'RE SUPPORT. OF THIS
MEASURE AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THE OLD SCHOOL ARE ON THE
PHONE I PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION IN A POSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- PUBLIC
GARCIA WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND SUPPORT. GIVE
ANYONE ELSEIN THE ROOM-
WANTING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. SEE NO ONE-
MISTER MODERATOR. IF WE HAVE
ANY INDIVIDUALS IN THE QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT- LET'S DO THAT NOW.
HERE WE HAVE A LINE NINETEEN
AND IF THERE ARE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT ME PRESS ONE ZERO NINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ONE OF THEM DONALD UP WITHOUT A
ONE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT ALSO
ON BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT PERSON. YOU FOR THAT. WE
HAVE SEVERAL OTHERS IN Q. WE
WILL BE JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU.
BOTTOM LINE FIFTY ONE FIVE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE FIVE
ZERO FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR MARK
THANK YOU MAKE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
INTO PORT. YOU FOR THAT. IN
LINE FIFTY TWO FIVE TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
RIGHT COMMISSION EACH PART OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
KNOW OTHERS IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED-
WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION BUT
I'LL ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. THAT IS THE ONE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEE NO ONE WE WILL NOW ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY INDIVIDUALS ON
THE PHONE LINE. WHO ARE.
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY ONE ZERO SIX
MISTER MODERATOR. THERE IS ON
ANYONE ON ON PHONE WITH THAT
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NOT WANTING
TO AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ON
THIS BILL IS THERE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. MOTION IN THE FOUR
ZERO SEVEN FIVE THREE MEN.
AREN'T ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- MISTER YOUR KERR
WOULD LIKE CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL. Q.
WITH THAT THIS IS AB TWENTY ONE
OH SIX WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
OF THE CHAIRS MOTION SECOND.
WAS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. EDUARDO GARCIA
BY THE BORDER GARCIA HI MEGHAN
DALLY. MEGAN DALY AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW I FLORA FLORA HI CHIU.
TWO I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA AUSTIN A GARCIA
I GLORIA GLORIA HI. KALRA KALRA
I. LEVINE LEVINE I OFFICE
MATHIS I BLANCA RUBIO. LOCAL%
RUBIO AYE SALAS. SALAS I WOULD
WOOD I THE VOTE IS FOURTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU THE BILL MOVES-
TODAY'S MEETING THANK YOU.
SUMMER WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
SIX AND- ITEM SIX IS A. B. TWO
FIVE ONE NINE BUT AFTER WOULD
CONSERVATION PROJECTS WE HAVE A
WITNESSES THAT WILL BE PROVIDED
TESTIMONY VIA TELEPHONE NUMBER
AND AN ORDER FROM THE ROLE
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES-
CALIFORNIA SO WOOD FLOORS ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN
SEEKS TO ADDRESS A SHORT COMING
IN THE GRANT PAYMENT PROCESS.
AND CUT THE GREEN TAPE THAT IS
PREVENTING RESTORATION PROJECTS
AND LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. AS IT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW GRANT AWARD T.
AWARDING MUST FLOW THE COST THE
GRANT WAS AWARDED TO COVER AND
APPLY FOR REIMBURSEMENT FROM
THE AWARDING AGENCY AFTER THE
FACT. THIS IS PROBLEMATIC FOR A
FEW REASONS FIRST THE NONPROFIT
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT APPLY FOR THESE
GRANTS OFTEN DO NOT HAVE THE
CAPITAL ON HAND. TO COVER THE
UP FRONT EXPENSES OR THEY
QUALIFY FOR A SEPARATE SERB
PATIENT MARKET RATE LOAN TO
RESOLVE THIS CASH FLOW
PROBLEMS. SECOND EVEN IF THEY
FIND A WAY TO GET THE PROJECT
OFF THE GROUND THEY HAVE TO
WAIT MONTHS AFTER THE PROJECT
IS COMPLETED TO RECEIVE
REIMBURSEMENT. OPERATING WITH
THESE COSTS LOOMING OVER THEIR
HEADS. THIS IS AN ARDUOUS
PROCESS AND SIMPLY NOT
REALISTIC. MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
THESE IMPACTS THIS IMPACTS
DISADVANTAGES DISADVANTAGED IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE
IS LESS CAPACITY TO SUPPORT
PROJECTS. THE RESULT IS THAT
THE COMMUNITIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS BOTH IN MY
DISTRICT IN SOME THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. OR UNABLE TO UC'S GRANT
DOLLARS EVEN AFTER THEY HAVE
BEEN AWARDED AND THE IMPORTANT
WORK IN ADVANCE IS THE STATE
GOALS IS UNABLE TO BE TO
PROCEED IN A TIMELY MANNER. THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY COASTAL
CONSERVANCY DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND STATE WATER BOARD
TO PROVIDE 20% 25% OF A GRANT
IN ADVANCE. FROM THE FUNDS A
CORRECT IF PROJECTS. RESILIENCE
DOORS. CORPORATE PRESERVES
LANDS. I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS BILL WOULD NOT IMPACT
OFTEN AS A LEAD. DOES NOT THE
APP OR REQUIRE. ADVANCE
PAYMENTS OF MONEY FUNDED BY
BONDS LIKE PROPOSITION ONE
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT. ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT SOME OF THE
AGENCIES CONCERNS ABOUT THE
RISK OF PROVIDING ADVANCE
PAYMENT. WILL POINT OUT THAT
THE STATUS QUO IS UNSUSTAINABLE
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE AFTERMATH
OF KOBE NINETEEN. IT WILL BE
IMPERATIVE TO DEPLOY STATE
DOLLARS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
HERE TESTIFYING SUPPORT IS
KAREN BIRD THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. OF CUT RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT AND
MARIAN WARMER DAM SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
REAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
WITNESSES MAY PROCEED. A GOOD
MORNING BUT THERE AND NUMBER
AYE AND KAREN BIRD THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND. AND WE ARE HERE
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN OF BOTH
BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT TO GET
LOCAL CONSERVATION DONE BUT
ALSO IT'S GOING TO BE CRITICAL
AS PART OF THE RECOVERY EFFORT
AND ECONOMIC STIMULUS. FOR A
LOCAL DISTRICT. I CALIFORNIA'S
COMES OVER NINETY FIVE ARE JUST
AFTER TWENTY FIVE REPORTS ON
DEBATE BUT THE RURAL URBAN AND
SUBURBAN POPULATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF LOCAL ACT ACT EXPERT ON THE
GROUND AND MAKING CONSERVATION
HAPPEN EVERY DAY- AS WELL AS
EMPLOYING PEOPLE AND KEEPING
AND KEEPING FOLKS WORKING. SO
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE CASH FLOW WOULD
BE ABLE TO FIND- THE PROJECT
THAT ARE KEEPING AT PEOPLE FACE
THAT ARE KEEPING FIRES AND FOR
A FIRE FROM HAPPENING. IN FOR
IT AND ALL THE KEEPING PEOPLE
AN EMPLOYEE DOING THOSE JOBS.
AND WAITING FOR GRANT THAT THE
PAY AS BACK FOR THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING REALLY HAMPERED OUR
ABILITY TO GET THE WORK DONE IT
KEEPS US FROM BEING EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT. AND IT KEEPS US
FROM DOING THE REALLY IMPORTANT
WORK THAT YOU REQUIRE AND MEET
OUR NEEDS TO DO- SO WE REALLY
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME AND THIS
MORNING IN LISTENING TO IT AND
IN THE THINK OF THE BILL. AND
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT HEARING
THIS MEASURE AND RECORD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. THAT YOU
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETEEN. THANK YOU LAST NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. CONFIRM. GOOD
MORNING CARE GARCIA AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MERION WARMER DAM ON BEHALF OF
OURS WE ARE THREE AS NOTED
EARLIER WE REPRESENT THIRTY
SEVEN IN THE STATE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY I'M AND WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY BOTH TO TESTIFY
AND MISTER WOODS IS OFFERING OF
THIS MEASURE. MANY OF OUR
MEMBER COUNTIES ARE HEAVILY
FORESTED AND COLLABORATE WITH
OUR LOCAL CONSERVATION
PARTNERS. IN MANAGING IN COUNTY
RESOURCES PARTICULARLY ARE
WATERSHED AREA. THESE PROJECTS
ARE KEY TO EFFORTSTHAT MIGHT
MITIGATE THE SEVERITY OF OUR
WILD FIRES AND IMPROVING THE
HEALTH OF OUR WATERSHED BOTH IN
TERMS OF WATER QUALITY AND
QUANTITY. WELL THE WORK HAVE
BEEN ONGOING IT HAS BEEN
EVIDENT THE DEGREE AS WE LOOK
INTO THE FUTURE THAT FINANCIAL
RESOURCES OFTENTIMES LAG AND
CREATE IMPEDIMENTS TO
CONTINUING ON WITH THIS
IMPORTANT WORK. AS NOTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETEEN WILL PROVIDE
ADVANCE ACCESS TO THESE BURNS
THEREBY MINIMIZING FUNDING GAP
AND MAINTAINING WORK SCHEDULES.
MANY OF THE COUNTIES IN
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SEEK THESE
GRANT FUNDS ARE LIMITED BY
TIGHT BUDGET. WITH LITTLE IN
THE WAY OF RESEARCH. THIS
MEASURE WILL ALLOW PROJECTS TO
BE JUMP STARTED WHILE
MAINTAINING THE PRUDENCE. WITH
BE ADVANCE PROVIDE BY THE
MEASURE THE PROSPECT ARE
RESTORATION EFFORTS WILL ALSO
BE ENHANCED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND THOSE AREAS
ONLY SERVED BY SMALLER LOCAL
CONSERVATION ENTITIES FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY AB TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL NOW.
ASK MR MODERATOR IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE TELEPHONE THAT
WILL BE- PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR
THIS MEASURE WERE ASKING THAT
THE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN IF THERE ARE
OTHERS YOU MAY PRESS ONE THAN
ZERO. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THE DESPAIR
HAPPENING TO CONSERVANCY AND
ALSO THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF
THE PACIFIC FOR STRUCK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETEEN THANKS VERY MUCH.
YOU. THANKS NO OTHER THAN Q. AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE IN THE
FLOOR ON THE FLOOR IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT THOUGH I WAS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. OKAY SEEN NINE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. BUT WILL ASK IF
OTHERS ANYONE HERE PRESIDENT
WANTING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MATTER. SEE NO ONE-
WILL ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE TELEPHONE LINE- WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THERE IS
SOMEONE IN TUCKER POSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. MORNING
TO YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU.
NO ONE AND HE
SAID NO ONE OR ONE IN THE IN
THE QUEUE. I FOLLOWED YOU KNOW
WHAT OKAY AND I. OKAY SO. THE
DELAY OF GAME HERE THE SITE WE
WILL ASK- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IS OUR MOTION OR SECOND
TO MOVE HIS BILL. SHE GLORIA
MOVES A BILL SHE IS SECONDS
BILL. THERE AREN'T ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. WE
WOULD LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO THANK
CLOSE BY THANKING COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR ADVICEAND
SUGGESTIONS ON THE BILL ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
PREVIOUS WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. BUT FOR TO CONTINUE WORK
ON THE BILL FOURTEEN A SOLUTION
AND MAKES THE GRANT PAYMENT
SYSTEM MORE USER FRIENDLY FOR
APPLICANTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I. BUT- YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WOULD
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE- THE
SECOND CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE WATER GARCIA HI. AND WHAT
OF. HI MEGAN DALLY. MEGAN DALLY
I BIGELOW BIGELOW I FLORA FLORA
I CHIU. TWO I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I GLORIA. GLORIA I KALRA
KALRA I LEVINE LEVINE I MATHIS
MATHIS I BLANCA RUBIO UNCLE
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I WOULD I
WOULD I. THE VOTERS FOURTEEN
ZERO WE'LL GET OUT PREPARATIONS
WILL NOW ASK ITEM TO BE
PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY. HE DOES HAVE- TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE
TESTIFYING ONE IN ABOUT TWO IN
PERSON LAST AND TO PLEASE STEP
BE PREPARED TO DO SO AS WELL AS
THOSE CALLING AND MR MCCARTY
TREASURES. THANK YOU THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT- STRONGLY AUTHORED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AND I
AM AVAILABLE TO BE HERE TODAY-
OF COURSE WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A CO THE NINETEEN CRISIS IN.
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA BUT
REALLY THE THREAT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO FOR THOSE THAT YOU
KNOW HISTORY IS OUR FLOODING.
AS AS A MISTER- COOLEY WOULD
SAY FOR ANSWER CANNELLA TO GIVE
THE HISTORY THE CAPITAL THIS
CAPITAL IS ACTUALLY RAISED UP
AND IT WAS MOVED OUT OF THE
AREA BECAUSE OF THAT. THE
FLOODING- DAMAGES OVER THE PAST
HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS AND WE KNOW
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE A HUNDRED.
ONE SIXTEEN HUNDRED MILES OF
LEVEES UP AND DOWN THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA TO
PROTECT THE LIVES AND PROPERTY
OF RESIDENTS. THESE ENGINES
STRUCTURES ARE PREVENTED ARE
DESIGNED TO PREVENT FLOODING.
OF COURSE AND LEVEES REQUIRE
REGULAR OPERATE IN MAINE IS A
PROTECTION AGAINST EROSION
THREATS. OVER THE YEARS
COMBINED STATE LOCAL MONEY TO
FIX OUR LEVEES HAVE A HEATED.
BILLION IN AND ESTIMATE.
HOWEVER ONE OF THE THREATS THAT
WE WERE. THIS LOCALLY HERE. IS
AN ALL. LEVY AND FORCE THE BUS.
BY PEOPLE CAMPING DOWN THERE.
AND THESE TAX. ARE A GROWING
THREAT TO THE INTEGRITY
INSTABILITY OF THE LEVEE SYSTEM
TO PROTECT. LARGE AREAS OF
SACRAMENTO FROM FLOODING- THIS
MEASURE- SIMPLY STRENGTHENS
PROTECTIONS AGAINST
UNAUTHORIZED EXCAVATIONS CUTS
ALTERATIONS INSTRUCTIONS OF THE
LEVEE SYSTEM. IN ORDER TO
PROTECT- THE PERMANENT- NATURE
OF OUR LEVEES. AND HELP US
PREVENT FLOODING DISPLACEMENT
OF RESIDENTS AND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN DAMAGE TO HOMES
PROBABLY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
DAMAGE TO HOMES. AND
PROPERTIES- I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT WITH ME TO DATE. ARE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM A CENTRAL
VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION BOARD.
AND ARE BACK. DISTRICT ONE THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS
REVIEW WE HAVE A MOTION BERMAN
FLORA. AND YOUR WITNESS NOW OF
READY TO GO SO PLEASE A-
PROCEEDED BELIEVE THEY'RE HERE
PERSON. QUESTIONS ON US FORTY
THREE I PLEASE COME FORWARD IN
TWO MINUTES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR GARCIA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HER
NAME IS TERRENCE IN A POLICY
ADVISER FOR THE CENTER VALLEY
FOR PROTECTION BOARD- WE- ARE-
OVERSEE- THE SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER SYSTEMS AND ITS
TRIBUTARIES- WHICH ALSO
GOVERNED THIS STATE PLAN FLOOD
CONTROL WE ARE- NONFATAL
SPONSORS TO THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS THAT PROVIDE
ASSURANCES. FOR PROPER
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE OF
THE SERIES OF LEVIES DAMS
WEIR'S BY PASSES IN CHANNELS
THAT MAKE UP THE STATE PLAN FOR
CONTROL OF ONE OF THE ACT
THANK- ON BEHALF OF HE BOARD
WANT TO THANK CHAIRED GARCIA
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING. WE APPRECIATE CHARTER
SEE IS ROLLING PARTICIPATION AS
AN EX OFFICIO MEMBER OF OUR
BOARD I ALSO WANTED TO TAKE
THIS MOMENT TO THANK- THE
AUTHORS- SOME REMEMBER MCCARTY
SOME OF COOPER AND ALL CO
AUTHORS WHICH INDUCES BILL THAT
WE BELIEVE. WILL MINIMIZE STATE
LIABILITY PROTECT THE LIVES OF
OUR PROPERTY AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- WE-
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT. YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WHAT. TWENTY CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS KEVIN KING GENERAL
MANAGER RECLAMATION DISTRICT
ONE THOUSAND- HERE IN
SACRAMENTO MY DISTRICT PROVIDES
FOR PROTECTION FOR THEM TO
THOMAS BASIN WHICH ENCOMPASSES
ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND ACRES OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS TO
MAJOR INTERSTATES AND I'M A
MAJOR INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT IN
THE SACRAMENTO AIRPORT. WE ARE
ONE OF THE MOST URBANIZED
RECOGNITION DISTRICTS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. AND THE PRIMARY
METHOD BY WHICH WE PROVIDE FOR
PROTECTION AS A FOUR FORTY SIX
MILES EXTERIOR THAT THE SYSTEM
THAT LEVY SYSTEM HOLDS BACK
FLOOD WATERS FROM THREE MAJOR
TRIBUTARIES THE SACRAMENTO THE
OTHER IN AMERICA MEMBERS. TO
RELATE TO THE SPEAR OF THE TIP
FOR FLOOD PROTECTION AT THOSE
THE CONFLUENCE OF THOSE THREE A
MAJOR RIVER SYSTEMS. PRIMARY TO
US BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN AND
OPERATE THAT LEVY SYSTEM OLDS
BACK THE FLOODWATERS IS THE
ABILITY TO SEE AND INSPECT THE
LEVY SYSTEM ON A CONTINUAL
BASIS. DURING THE SPRING OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- WITH THE-
RECORD SNOW PACK IN THIS YEAR
AS- WE WERE UNABLE TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE THERE WERE THESE
PHYSICAL OBSTRUCTIONS TO THE
LEVY SYSTEM. A CERTAIN SIX MILE
STRETCH OF OUR DISTRICT HAD
EIGHTY ONE OBSTRUCTIONS THE
PREVENTED US FROM INSPECTING
NOT LEVY SYSTEM. UNDER WHICH WE
FOUND. IT AT LEAST THREE OR
FOUR EXCAVATIONS THAT WE HAD
BEEN ABLE TO SEEING WITH THE
OBSTRUCTIONS IN PLACE. I CAN
CAUTION YOU THAT WE'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH KATRINA AND THE
VISUAL- ASKED VISUAL THINGS
THAT WE SAW ON PEOPLE WAITING
THROUGH THE WATERS IN NEW
ORLEANS. THAT WON'T HAPPEN IN
THE THOMAS THAT WATER
TEMPERATURES FIFTY FIVE DEGREES
AND FIFTY FIVE DEGREES YOUR
BODY LOSES MUSCLE CONTROL AFTER
THREE MINUTES I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGES SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LOS BECAUSE
MODERATOR IFFY. HAS ANY
INDIVIDUALS IN THE QUEUE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. HAVE ALMOST NINE
FORTY THREE ISRAEL HAD. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ROBERT COR FROM THE
GLOBAL GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD CONTROL
AGENCY OR SAVE CA WE ARE DEEPLY
INDEBTED TO MR COOPER FOR
OFFERING THIS BILL AND AS MR
MCCARTY JUST SAID THERE WILL BE
FLOOD WITH CLIMATE CHANGE THE
FLOOD WILL BE. BIGGER AND MORE
SUDDEN A LEVEE BREACH WOULD BE
A PROLONGED CATASTROPHE FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE ESPECIALLY IN THE
SAFE AREA WHICH THE U. S. ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS IS RATED-
THE MOST AT RISK IN THE IN THE
COUNTRY AND THE ALSO URGING
EUROPE APPROVAL TODAY IS THE
MARKETING REPORT THROUGH THE
GIVES BUT- WE GET YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
IN WE HAD THE TWO WITNESSES
ALREADY SPEAK OF WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
ROBERT CORPORAL ACOSTA WORKED
ON BEHALF OF SAFE CAN STRUCK
SUPPORT.ANYONE ELSE ON THE
LINE MISS MODERATOR FOR SUPPORT
HIS MEASURE. TAKE A OF OUR LINE
SIXTY THREE THE- GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CLIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
DEADLINE- SIXTY TWO BECAUSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER ACROSS QUICKLY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU YEAH LINE FIFTY ONE THE
THOUGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS MERION
WARMER DAM ON BEHALF OF RC RC
SUPPORT THE BILL. YOU GO LINE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
SURE THIS IS MICHAEL WITH THE
WESTERN FEDERAL LAW POVERTY
AFFECTS THE TRYING TO GET IN-
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. LET ME.
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND PROCEED TO
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION. ALL WE ARE ONLY
TAKE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
THE- PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER- MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND I APOLOGIZE TO THE
COMMITTEE IN THE MEMBERS AND
THE AUTHOR FOR- I THOUGHT WE
HAD ISSUED A LETTER SUBMITTED A
LETTER ON THIS BUT APPARENTLY
DID NOT OR NOT WITHIN THE FILE
SO I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT WE
DO BOTH THE BILL AND WE THANK
YOU FOR NUMBER VERSION THE BILL
LAST YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SO WILL TAKE ANY OTHER CALLS
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. OF THE
MEASURE. BEFORE WE GO TO FOLKS
THAT ARE PRESENT- THAT ONE IS-
GIVE THEIR SUPPORT ANYONE ELSE
ON IN THE QUEUE MISTER
MODERATOR IN SUPPORT. NO
FURTHER THANK YOU THANK YOU NOW
ASK FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE-
PRESIDENT- TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BABRI BUT WITH REAP
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CENTER VALLEY
FLOOD CONTROL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK- IN SUPPORT
ADD TO THE SUPPORT LAST. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. OKAY
SEE NO ONE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE- OPPOSITION THERE ARE TWO.
WITNESSES AT OF REGISTER TO
SPEAK TODAY- TESTIFYING VIA
TELEPHONE SHARON RAPPER FROM
THE CORPORATION SUPPORT OF
HOUSING CHRISTOPHER MARTIN
HOUSING CALIFORNIA IF- THEY ARE
IN THE QUEUE WAS MODERATOR
LET'S LET'S BEGIN. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHARON
REPORT AND I WORK ON CALIFORNIA
POLICY FOR THE CORPORATION
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR NATIONAL
NONPROFIT WORKING TO FALL. MATH
WE REGRETFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND LAST
NAME THAT. WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE OF THE
TENSION AMENDMENTS AND PRE
APPRECIATE THEIR EFFORTS TO
WORK WITH THAT THE BALLPARK.
BOBBI IS NOW TO CRIMINALIZE. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY WHAT. HELLO LAW
ENFORCEMENT ADVANCE AND
INCARCERATION OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. AND
POTENTIAL PLEASE SOMETHING CARE.
AND THE REMOVAL OF BELONGINGS
BUT NAY CONSTITUTE AN
INDIVIDUALS OR FAMILIES WELL
CONVENTION. AB NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT THREATENS TO PERPETUATE
THE CONDITION CONTRIBUTING
HOMELESS IS INCREASINGLY
RECOGNIZED BY ADVOCATE.
JURISDICTIONS AND COURT OF
EXACERBATING THE CRISIS.
CRIMINALIZATION MAKES IT HARDER
FOR PEOPLE TO GET HOW OLD DO
THE CRIMINAL RECORDS AND THAT
HAPPENED BECAUSE OF AN
INABILITY TO PAY WE ARE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE BILL'S IMPACT AS WE'RE FREE
THANKS FOR INCREASES IN
HOMELESSNESS DIFFICULT AT
NINETEEN AND AT THE CDC AND HAD
HAVE ADVISED BUT REMOVING
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS COULD
FURTHER THE SPREAD OF COKE THAT.
THE CIRCUIT IS INSECT CASE THE
FEDERAL HER A PROPERTY IS HOME
FIRST. AND REMOVING A- WITHOUT
EFFICIENCY TO ARE CON. FOR
THESE REASONS JOURNAL QUOTE
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER MARTIN
AND I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOCUSED ON
HOMELESSNESS WITH HOW THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC CALIFORNIA
THE NONPROFIT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WITH THE MISSION
TO ENSURE THAT NOBODY AT
HOMELESS AND EVERYONE
REGARDLESS OF INCOME HAS THE
STATE'S STABLE AFFORDABLE PLACE
TO LIVE. I AM ALSO SPEAKING TO
YOU TODAY ABOUT OUR OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND
EIGHTY NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT WE
DID SUBMIT A LETTER BUT ARE NOT
LISTED IN THE AND OUT THAT. NO
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS WORK
YOU NEED WITHOUT. TO RESOLVE
OUR CONCERNS WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL
THREATENS TO FURTHER
CRIMINALIZE. OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS THAT
OUT OF PLACE TO CALL HOME. IN
THE MIDST OF AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOME CRISIS THAT
HAD BEEN FURTHER EXACERBATED BY
COVERT NINETEEN. EIGHTY
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT WHAT ALLOW
FOR LOCAL AND BOND FORCED ME TO
A RACK INCARCERATE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
LIVING NEAR RIVER LACKEY.
EIGHTY NINETEEN FIFTY IT ALSO
PERMITS THE STATE FLOOD CONTROL
PLAN LOCAL AUTHORITY TO REMOVE
PEOPLE BELONGING. BY ALLOWING
AUTHORITY TO REMOVE PHYSICAL
OBSTRUCTIONS FROM LEVEES. I
WOULD CONCUR WITH THE STATEMENT
THE CHALLENGES MADE REGARDING
THE IMPACT OF CRIMINALIZATION
ON HOMELESSNESS AND THE
EXISTING KAPOK IN THE NINTH
CIRCUIT. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT A FEW
AMENDMENTS THAT WE BELIEVE
WOULD ALLEVIATE OUR POSITION.
OUR OUR OPPOSITION. WE LIKE THE-
BURKE HE USED ENFORCEMENT WHERE
THE EXTRA OF THE LEFT POSES THE
RED TO PUBLIC SAFETY. SECOND TO
ALLOW AT LEAST SEVENTY TWO
HOURS NOTICE WHEN IMMEDIATE
SAFETY IS NOT AT RISK TO PUT
HIM AT LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
COMPLICATING THOSE BELONGING.
AND FINALLY TO REQUIRE OF HE
THOUGHT THAT THERE TO BE
ACCOMPANIED BY A LOCAL HOME
WITH THEIR WITH PROVIDER WITH
CULTURAL COMPETENCY AND OUT
REACH WITH THE GOAL OF OFFERING
SERVICES THAT CAN HELP PEOPLE
ACT THAT A HOME. WITHOUT THESE
AMENDMENTS WE BELIEVE THE BILL
TAKE THE PUNITIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGE AND
WILL FURTHER EXACERBATE ARE ALL
OF THIS CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS TO FIND A SOLUTION
APPRECIATE THEIR WORK. WITH UP
TO THIS POINT AT THAT POINT
THOUGH WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE ON THE
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. THANKS
THANK YOU THAT'S OUR TWO
WITNESSES ASK- AGAINST THE BILL
ARE THERE ANY INDIVIDUALS HERE
WANTING. TO SPEAK AGAINST THE
BILL- THEIR PRESENT ANYONE. IN
THE GEN OUR MOTION BY MISTER
MATHIS. SECOND BY MISTER SALAS.
LET ME ASK LET ME CHECK AND SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY INDIVIDUALS-
IN THE QUEUE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE. YOU HAVE LINE TWENTY
TWO THE BILL HAS. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND NUMBER
CAPTURE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE- BEGETS WITNESSES
ALL. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER FOR
THEIR KIDS. DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINE
TO TESTIFY OR PROVIDE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THIS
TIME THEY'RE NOT GOING TO.
THANK YOU. I THINK I HEARD THAT
THERE ARE NONE I'LL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE DO
HAVE A MOTION- THERE IS A
SECOND WE HAVE TO MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK UP. FIRST IS
MISTER KALRA. YOU MISTER CHAIR-
AND THANK YOU DECEMBER MCCARTY
AS WELL AS A MEMBER COOPER
AUTHOR THIS BILL- I BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL. OF BRINGS
TOGETHER TWO DIFFERENT I THINK
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FACING AS AS A DISTRICT HAS
ACTUALLY. HAD FLOODING OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS I ABSOLUTELY.
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROTECTING THE INTEGRITY. OF
OUR LEVEES AND SO. I AGREE WITH
THE PREMISE THE BILL I ALSO.
AGREE THAT HAVE SIMILAR
CONCERNS IS THE OPPOSITION IS
PARTIALLY AS WE- SEE CURRENTLY
AS WELL AS THE POTENTIAL FOR AN
INCREASE IN OUR HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION- MEANT TO BE SENSE
OF THAT ISSUE AS WELL. IT'S
ENCOURAGING TO HEAR OPPOSITION-
HAVING CONSTRUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS. WITH THE OFFER
THE BILL I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN NARROW IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE- THAN IT CURRENTLY IS
WRITTEN IN TAXED. TERM OF. WE
HAVING A DESTRUCTION. OF THE
VIEW A LETTER YOU. DE CLEARLY
THERE'S DAMAGE OF CUTTING INTO
A LEVY. THAT IMPACTS THE
INTEGRITY. IT SHOULD BE THERE
THERE SHOULD BE ABOVE THE
AUTHORITY. FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE. TO
SPOT AT. YOU TO. IT'S ABOUT
THAT CAN BE I'M HOPEFUL BY THE
TIME THIS BILL REACHES THE
FLOOR GIVE THE COST CON
HAPPENING THAT THE BALANCE WILL
BE AND I LOOK FOR SUPPORT THE
BILL ON THE FLOOR WITH MORE
NEARLY CRAFTED TAX THANK YOU
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER VINCE.
CLARKE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO ASK THE BILL PRESENTED I
RECOGNIZE WHAT THE AUTHOR BUT
THE BILL PRESERVED MAYBE SPEAK
TO THE CONCERNS ABOUT
GLOBALIZATION. OF HOMELESSNESS
WHICH SHOULD BE A CONCERN THAT
I SHARE AS WELL. MATT PLEASE.
YEAH THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. SO LIKE I CONSIDER
THE SO YOU HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
PART OF MY POLICY AGENDA SO.
IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE HAVING US ON
OTHER SIDE I DO REPRESENT THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO. THIS IS A
REAL ISSUE. AS OUR SPEAKER
SAID. OUTSIDE NEW ORLEANS THIS
IS THE MOST DANGEROUS CITY. IN
AMERICA AS FAR AS FLOODING. IN
PEOPLE WOULD DIE WITHIN OUR
STATE THE LEVEES FOR. PEOPLE
LIVE UP IN THE THOMAS IN THE
POCKET. WOULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT IF HE'S LIKE
IT IT'S ARE SERIOUS THREAT WE
HAVE HERE. FOR A LOCAL AREA.
AND THERE ARE THERE ARE REACHED.
IT SHOULDN'T A CRIME TO BE.
MISSION DEALING TO BE POOR. IT
SHOULD BE A CRIME TO BE
HOMELESS MISSION CRIMINALIZE
HOMELESSNESS BUT THERE ARE
RESTRICTIONS YOU CAN'T. SLEEP
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE CAPITOL AT
NIGHT. THEY MAKE A MOVE ON. YOU
CAN'T SLEEP IN A STAIRWELL
UNDERNEATH A SCHOOL BECAUSE IT
IT IT HAS A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE
THERE ARE. LIMITED RESTRICTIONS
IN THIS SAYS IF YOU ARE IN THE
LEVY AREA. NOT A LITTLE BIT
BACK FROM THE LEFT IN THE
TREES. ALONG THE LEVY AND
PHYSICALLY KEEP IF YOU KNOW DIG
INTO IT AND CAUSE DAMAGE TO THE
LEVY. THAT CAUSES A THREAT TO
ALL OF US HERE AND SO- THIS IS
ACTUALLY- CLARIFIES NINETEEN
FORTY POLICY. RECLAMATION
DISTRICT- HAS BEEN FOCUSING ON
FOR YEARS AND GIVES MORE CLEAR
CLARITY TO OUR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IN A PREVIOUS AS
WHAT YOU CAN DO TO ENFORCE
POLICY- YOU WANT ANYTHING ELSE
MISTER DO. IN A CAN I
UNDERSTAND THAT PORTS OF SAFETY
I SERVE WOULD. ANYTHING THAT
PROTECTS- CALIFORNIANS BUT
SPEAKING SPECIFICALLY TO THE
CRIMINAL ON ASKING HEALTHY WITH
THAT YEAH. THE CRIMINAL THIS IS
AN EXISTING LAW YEAH SURE THANK
THANK YOU APPRECIATE
OPPORTUNITY- THAT THE EXISTING
LAW WAS WITH THE PROXY NINETEEN
FORTY THREE WHEN IT WHEN IT WAS
MADE IN THE FLIGHT SYSTEM WAS
ORIGINALLY- AUTHORIZES. AND
BUILT AND BACK THEN IT WAS FOR
DIFFERENT PURPOSES- THIS IS THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES- ALMOST
A CAMPING IN THE LEVEES
CREATES. A GREAT UNCERTAINTY
FOR INSPECTORS- IT IN AND- AND
THE REST THAT YOU THAT WE
DISCUSSED REAL. ABOUT THEM JUST
TO LET. THE INTENT IS NOT TO
CRIMINALIZE HOMELESSNESS- IS
NOT TO PROSECUTE BUT MERELY TO.
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
INSPECTORS TO GET AND MAKE SURE
THERE'S NO DAMAGES IF THERE IS
WE NEED TO REPAIR THE DAMAGES
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE BEFORE HIGH
WATER. RETURNS AND AS YOU KNOW
MOTHER NATURE HAS NOT
DETECTABLE AND SO THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW AND- WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK- WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS YOU HEARD EARLIER-
IT JUST PRESENTS- A DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE. GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY OF MOTHER NATURE
GIVEN THE UNCERTAINTY OF WIN
DAMAGES DO OCCUR WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT IT WE CAN'T SEE IT-
THERE'S NO TIME FRAME THAT THAT
REALLY LENDS ITSELF TO THAT. SO
FORGIVE MY IGNORANCE OF IN MY
DISTRICT WE WISH WE HAD WATER-
AND SO THIS IS NOT A CONCERN
THE MEAN ESTIMATE INTERFACE WE
DO HAVE HOMELESS. ARE THEIR
ACTIVATION TO THE LEFT BUT
PEOPLE WHO SHELTERED. IN ALL
WAYS EXCLUSIVELY ON SHOPPING IN.
I COULDN'T. THAT THAT. I WOULD
SAY THE THERE THERE'S PEOPLE
WHO IF THEY'RE OUT THERE THEY
HAVE SHOWN. HI ARE YOU ASKING
IS THERE ARE THERE UNLAWFUL SEE
THROUGH THE CHAIR. YEAH I YOU
ASKING THERE ON. ACTS TODAY
THAT ARE DONE BY PEOPLE THAT
ARE NOT HOMELESS CORRECT
PROBABLY NOT OKAY I NOT PEOPLE
THAT THAT WOULDN'T BE OUT THERE
WITH A SHOVEL DIGGING. DIGGING
IN AND LET'S FACE IT THE
CONDITIONS ARE HORRIFIC IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE AT HOME. SO I
DON'T I DON'T NECESSARILY- YOU
KNOW WHAT TO DO TO PUT IT IS
INDIVIDUALS ON A NEGATIVE LIGHT
BUT IT IS A REALITY OUT THERE
AND IF YOU LITERALLY WALK TWO
MILES FROM HERE. IN LESS THAN A
HALF HOUR WE COULD GO SHOW YOU
AREAS WHERE INDIVIDUALS
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE DUG OUT
PORTIONS OF THE LEVY AND
NEEDED- UNSTABLE. SO THAT
PRESENTS A THREAT TO OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY HERE IN SACRAMENTO THE
WHEN A SENSE OF THE SO YOUR
QUESTION WAS IS THERE SHELTERED
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE CAUSING
DAMAGE TO THE LEVY SYSTEMS OFF
THE ANSWERS YET. AND NO YES
YEAH THIRTY THERE ARE THERE TO
RESIGN CAN YOU TO STATE YOUR
NAME ON KEVIN CAME RIGHT IS OR
WHAT THE- THERE ARE AND THERE'S
A PER PROCESS FOR THAT.
INCIDENT AS WE GOT MISS BACK
WHETHER IT'S A HOMEOWNER PUT AN
OFFENSE FOR GATE ON THEIR
PROPERTY OR PLACING ROCK IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A PERMIT FOR
THAT. AND THEY'RE DIGGING TO
PROVIDE EXCAVATIONS ABSOLUTELY
ON TOP. AND SO THIS IS.
NECESSARY HOMELESSNESS THIS
BILL CLARIFIES LANGUAGE THAT
INCLUDES PEOPLE. THAT OWN
PROPERTY. THAT ARE OCCUPYING
THE- THERE ARE NOT SO APPLIES
TO ALL IT'S NOT JUST HOMELESS
BILL IN THIS IS WHERE THE NEAR
COUNTY CHANGED YES THE LYRICIST
IS IMPACTED BY HOMES AND THE
PROBLEM IS SO THAT I. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS POINT OF NARROWING IT
DOWN TO THE MAYBE THE VISUAL
THERE THAT'S A TOOL WE HAVE
THREE X. RAY LAST YEAR THAT THE
IN HAD FALLEN THAT WERE COVERED
UP. WE CAN SEE THAT UNTIL
INVOLUNTARILY THAT WE CAME BACK
THREE DAYS LATER TO REPAIR THE
SITE IT WAS COVERED AGAIN WE
NEVER SEEN I WOULD NOT HAVE HAD
THAT OPPORTUNITY SO ANYWAY
THERE ARE SOLDIERS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT POINT IN. AND THAT'S
IT THE PERSONALLY TO ME THAT
THE RULES OF THE CREATING THE
STATE SIDE EVERYONE EQUALLY.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT FOR
THOSE THAT THE CONCERNS
RECOMMENDATION OF ALMOST AS IF
YOU'RE CREATING A LOT OF THE
ONLY APPLY TO THE HOMELESS.
WOULD ONLY DIRECTLY IMPACT AND
OF THAT WOULD BE A HUGE PROBLEM
FOR THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT
I'M HEARING YOU SAY IS THAT
THERE INDIVIDUALS. OF ALL
HOUSING TYPES A SHELTER. FOR
HOMELESS LAW WOULD APPLY FOR A
PROGRAM YOU WOULD APPLY IT THAT
YOU WOULD FORCE AGAINST AND
DAD. WHAT IS SO INFURIATING I
APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING THAT ON
THE RECORD TO GET SOME SUPPORT
TODAY- I WOULD ASK YOU TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPONENTS IN THIS PARTICULAR.
MATTER TO MAKE SURE THAT WHAT
WE'RE CREATING HERE IS NOT A
DOUBLING DOWN OF THE KINDS OF
STRATEGIES THAT WE KNOW DEL.
SOL HOMELESSNESS- WHAT I FIND
IS A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE TO
PEOPLE LIKE SIMPLISTIC
SOLUTIONS FOR. AND SIMPLY
WALKING THESE FOLKS OUT AS WE
KNOW IS NOT A STRATEGY AND
IMPORTANTLY IT'S EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE AND WE DON'T A LOT OF
EXTRA MONEY NINETY DAYS. SO I
RESPECT IN THE KNOWLEDGE THAT I
DON'T KNOW A GREAT DEAL ABOUT
LEVEES AGAIN NOT A CONCERN THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO SO I WILL
SUPPORT. THE BILL TODAY- BUT I
WILL ASK FOR CONTINUE MY CASE
TO MAKE SURE IF YOU CAN STAND
UP SAY LIGHT OF DAY. THIS IS
NOT AN- THE MOST. AMONG US A IT
WILL LOOK FOR THE SCENE DOES
NOT. JUST TO MAKE IT FOR THE
SUMMER. THANK YOU MISTER. WELL
WE DO HAVE. TO COLLEAGUES.
QUESTIONS MISTER. CANCER JUNE.
BOB GARCIA. THANK YOU MISTER. A
THE WAR SUPPORT OF REAL. I VERY
STRONG AND- IN PROTECT. OUR
VERY FOR. IN FIRST. BY THE AYE.
TO ENCOURAGE TO ALL. WHO
BECAUSE OFFICER. A TWO MAKE
SURE THAT REALLY CLEAR TO ME
THAT WERE. FROM A HOMELESS. SO
ARE. THE RIGHT TO BONO. AND ON
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU. SOME OF
OUR- YEAH OUR THINKING I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL. I'VE SEEN
SOME OF THIS INFORMATION IN MY
DISTRICT AS WELL AND I
UNDERSTAND THE PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS WE HAVE OUT THERE BUT
I DO HAVE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT
FOR THEIR CRIMINAL I SEEN ONE
OF OUR POPULATIONS HOMELESS
POPULATIONS AND SO. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE AS THIS MOVES TO THE
FLOOR THAT ARE STAKEHOLDERS
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO SOFTEN
THAT LANDING THERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBERS- SEE
NINE NO OTHER MEMBER. RAISING A
MICROPHONE WE'VE- IN SOME INPUT
ON THE BILL DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND DESERVE SECOND. MOTION
SECOND THAT WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
YES THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO- CO PRESENTS- THE LEAD
AUTHORS OF COURSE RIGHT HERE SO
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR HIM BUT- WHO
I AM AS A PERSON WAS NAME UP
THERE RIGHT WITH MISTER COOPER
WILLING TO TALK TO THE-
OPPONENTS OF FURTHER
REVALUATION THEIR PROPOSALS-
THIS IS A DELICATE BALANCE YOU
KNOW. TWO CRITICAL ISSUES HERE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA AND OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES RELATED TO- FLOOD
CONTROL SO WE'RE TRYING TO
STRIKE A FAIR BALANCE AND I
THINK THIS MEASURE ATTEMPTS TO
DO SO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK AT
IT AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF. THANK YOU THIS
MORNING AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE RIVAL. MEASURE DOES HAVE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WHO
APPROPRIATIONS- WHICH-
SECRETARY PLEASE KALRA. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA HI MEGHAN DALLY. MEGAN
DALY AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW I
FLORA FLORA I JUNE. TWO I
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA. KALRA NOT
VOTING LEVINE. LEVINE I MATHIS
MATHIS HI BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I WOULD.
WOOD I. THE VOTE IS THIRTEEN TO
ZERO WITH ONE NOT VOTING
ALRIGHT THANK YOU THE BILL WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OPERATIONS
ALASKA- MISSED BLOOM WITH ITEM
TEN AB TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE.
AND TO ASK THE HIS WITNESSES-
HE- PREPARED IF THAT- TO THE
WILL TESTIFY IN PERSON. AND
THEN WE ASK THAT THOSE WHO
CALLED WHO WILL BE CALLING AND
SUPPORT PLEASE UP. FOR DOING SO
AT THIS TIME- MISTER BLOOM THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. A WITNESS%
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU- AND-
COULD MORNING MISTER TURNER
CALLING THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE THIS
MORNING. WHICH IS A BILL TO
RESTORE SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WATERSHEDS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE
BUILT. ON A LAW THAT I AUTHORED
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT
RECOGNIZE THAT WATERSHEDS ARE
AN ESSENTIAL PART OF OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND A LOT OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
PASSED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CALL FOR AN ASSESSMENT AND
PRIORITIZATION. OF THE
RESTORATION NEEDS IN THE WATER
SHOWS THAT FLOW INTO SHASTA
TRINITY AND- FOR A BILL
RESERVOIRS. THESE LARGEST
RESERVOIRS FORM THE BACKBONE OF
THE STATE'S WATER SYSTEM
PROVIDING UPWARDS OF. ATWATER
TO UPWARDS OF TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE AND MOST OF THE
IRRIGATED AGRICULTURE AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THIS PROPOSAL
CREATES AN INTER AGENCY SHASTA
TRINITY OR OF WILL WATERSHED
RESTORATION ADMINISTRATION THAT
WOULD BE HOUSED AT THE WATER
BOARD TO COORDINATE RESTORATION
AND CONSERVATION INVESTMENTS IN
THIS REGION. LED BY A STEERING
COMMITTEE OF THE KEY
ORGANIZATIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL ESTABLISH
AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN TO
EFFICIENTLY EXECUTE THE
RESTORATION PROJECTS OVER THE
NEXT FIFTEEN YEARS. IT WOULD
ALSO MAKE DIRECTED GRANTS FROM
THE EXISTING HEADQUARTERS
RESTORATION FUNDS TO IMPLEMENT
THE PLAN. THE RESTORATION OF
THESE WATERSHED WILL PLACE THEM
IN THE BEST CONDITION POSSIBLE
TO REDUCE FIRE IMPACT IMPROVE
WATER SECURITY ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ASSIST AND SUSTAIN
THEIR LONG TERM HEALTH. THE
EXECUTION OF THIS PLAN WILL
ALSO SERVE AS AN ECONOMIC
DRIVER CREATE JOBS IN A PART OF
THE STATE WITH HISTORICALLY
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT. AND SOME SAY
THAT THE STATE IS ALREADY
MAKING INVESTMENT IN THE REGION
SO WHY DO WE NEED THIS NEW
INTER AGENCY EFFORT THAT'S A
VALID QUESTION. BUT IT'S A
MATTER OF HAVING A PLAN AND A
SYSTEM TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE OUR
GOALS AT SCALE. DURING THE
CLOVER CRISIS OUR ATTENTION IS
RIGHTFULLY FOCUSED ON DIRECT
RESPONSES TO OUR MOST PRESSING
NEEDS. AND IN ITS WAKE THE
PANDEMIC IS PUT MANY OF OUR
PRIORITIES AND NEEDS AS A STATE
ON HOLD. BUT CLIMATE CHANGE
WHILE FIRE WATER SECURITY AND
ROCK RELIABILITY AND THE NEED
FOR JOBS. WILL NOT WAIT AND WE
MUST CONTINUE TO EXPEDITIOUSLY
PREPARE OUR STATE FOR AND
IDENTIFIED SOLUTIONS TO THESE
ONGOING CONCERNS. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY THREE IS A STRATEGIC AND
EFFICIENT APPROACH BASED ON A
DATA DRIVEN ASSESSMENT. THAT
WILL SERVE AS AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF OUR STATE ONGOING RESPONSE
TO THESE ISSUES. I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY OPPOSITION AND I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT I AM
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROPOSED ADMINISTRATION IS
INCLUSIVE AND REPRESENTATIVE OF
LOCAL INTEREST EXISTING PLANTS.
AND THE WORK THAT IS ALREADY
BEING CARRIED OUT IN THE REGION.
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE IS
MEANT TO BE COMPLEMENTARY TO
THOSE EFFORTS AND AGAIN I'M
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT THAT
IS THE CASE. IN FACT ONLY
YESTERDAY. I HAVE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH IZZY MARTIN
OF THE SIERRA FUND AND JONATHAN
TO SOUL OF THIS YEAR INSTITUTE
WHOSE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
CONDUCTING RESTORATION WORK IN
THESE WATERSHEDS. AND WHILE
THEY HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL AT THIS TIME. I THINK WE
ARE IN AGREEMENT ABOUT THE OVER
ARCHING GOALS THAT ARE PROPOSED
IN AB TWENTY SIX NINETY THREE.
AND WE'VE AGREED TO CONTINUE
MEETING BEGINNING WITH NEXT
WEEK. I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THEM AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. AND MAKE THE
WATERSHED RESTORATION
ADMINISTRATION AND EFFICIENT
MEANS OF FACLITATING THE
ESSENTIAL WORK THAT MUST BE
COMPLETED OUR STATE MOST
IMPORTANT WATERSHEDS. I'M
PLEASED TO HAVE WITH ME LAURIE
WAIVER THE PRESIDENT OF THE
PACIFIC FOR STRESS TO TESTIFY
WHAT. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
CHAIR GARCIA AND VICE CHAIR
DOLLY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
IN PARTICULAR MR BLOOM- AS WELL
AS THE STAFF OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES FOR PREPARING THIS
HEARING. AS WE SEE ALL AROUND
US- WITH THE VARIABLE WEATHER
AND WITH. THE EXACERBATIONS OF
ISSUES CAUSED BY THE CURRENT
CRISIS. CALIFORNIA HAS A SERIES
OF ISSUES THAT ARE URGENT A
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND MANY
AMONG THEM OUR- FIRE RISK
REDUCTION. WHAT A RELIABLE.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SUPPORTING
THE ECONOMIES AND UNDERSERVED
REGIONS OF THE STATE. THIS BILL
SETS FORWARD A PATH TO DEAL
WITH THOSE PROBLEMS AT SCALE.
AND DEALS WITH THEM IN THEIR
LINKED FASHION. IT WILL ALSO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ADDRESSING UNDER EMPLOYMENT IN
A CRITICAL REGION OF THE STATE
THAT STANDS OUT BOTH IN STATE
AND NATIONALLY FOR UNDER
EMPLOYMENT. THIS IS ANOTHER
DROUGHT HERE. IT IS A YEAR
WHERE WE ARE EXPECTING TO HAVE
A PROLONGED AND INTENSE FIRE
SEASON AGAIN. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH WAS ANOTHER
MAJOR FIRE YEAR FOR OF THE
STATE'S FIVE MEGA FIRES WERE IN
THIS REGION COSTING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS AND TENS OF
BILLIONS TO ADDRESS IN TERMS OF
RECOVERY. FAR IS DIRECTLY
IMPACTED PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS OUR WATER SUPPLY.
THURGOOD ON THE GROUND EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS THIS BUT THERE ARE
TOO FEW TOO SMALL AND TOO SLOW
TO EFFECTIVELY DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM AT THE SCALE THAT IS
NEEDED. AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
THREE ESTABLISHES A COORDINATED
INTER AGENCY OFFICE AND TEAM.
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES WITH
DIRECT RESPONSIBILITY AND
REGULATORY AUTHORITY IN THESE
WATERSHEDS OF THE DAMS. THAT
SERVES THE CORE OF THE STATE'S
WATER SYSTEM. IT IS TO BE
SUPPORTED BY AN DVISORY
COUNCIL WHICH INCLUDES DEEP ON
THE GROUND LOCAL EXPERIENCE
KNOWLEDGE AND INTERESTS AND
THAT IS INITIALLY DESCRIBED
ONLY IN THE BILL A PRESENT AS
THE AUTHOR HAS IDENTIFIED IS
VERY WILLING TO WORK WITH
ADDITIONAL INTERESTS AND HAVE
THEM INTO THAT. EVERYBODY LOVES
OUR WATERSHEDS BUT THE
UNFORTUNATE REALITY IS THERE IS
NO ENTITY THAT HAS
RESPONSIBILITY. TO TAKE CARE OF
THOSE WATERSHEDS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THAT. IT SETS OR WILL
SET CLEAR TARGETS IN ESTABLISH
RESPONSIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY RESTORING THESE
WATERSHEDS TO THEIR BEST
POSSIBLE FUNCTION. IT IS TO BE
HOUSE TO THE STATE WATER BOARD
BECAUSE THAT ENTITY HAS BOTH
THE EXPERIENCE OF DEALING WITH
LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
AND THE ABILITY TO HANDLE THE
KINDS AND SCALE OF FINANCING
THAT WILL BE NEEDED. TO MAKE
THIS EVER COME TO PASS. THERE
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE WITH THE
STATE REVOLVING FUNDS OF THE
CLEAN WATER DRINKING ACT AND
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER ACT-
POSITION IT TO HELP TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF EMERGING FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. FUNDING AND
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BOTH ON ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
FOR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE. IT'S
A VERY TIMELY BILL ADDRESSING
AN URGENT NEED TO REDUCE FIRE
RISK TO ENHANCE OUR WATER
SECURITY AND RELIABILITY IN THE
STATE WATER RELIABILITY IS
INDEED THE LIFEBLOOD FOR MUCH
OF THE ECONOMY. IN THE STATE.
IT SETS FORTH A NEW PARADIGM
AND PATH FORWARD ADDRESSING
BOTH SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM
RISKS AND IT WILL INCREASE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
INVESTMENTS. AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE ACTIVITIES
ON THE GROUND. IT WILL INCREASE
SAFETY WATER RELIABILITY AND
MOVE FORWARD OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION EFFORTS THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU- YOU HAVE YOU SAID YOU HAD
ONE WITNESS- THAT WILL BE
SPEAKING I'LL ASK IF THERE ARE
ANY INDIVIDUALS. THAT APPEAR
PRESIDENT- IN THE CHAMBERS AND
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THE MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC OURS ON
BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT. AND
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE.
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
FRIENDS OF HARBOUR BEACHES AND
PARKS. HERE FORCE LEGACY AND
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IMPACT OF
CULTURAL NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT THAT IS
PRESENT IN THE CHAMBERS SCENE
NO ONE IS MODERATOR ALASKA IF
YOU CAN. ANNOUNCER TO THOSE WHO
ARE PROVIDING SUPPORT VIA
TELEPHONE TO PLEASE DO SO AT
THIS TIME NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. CALL FIRST HOME LINE
SEVENTY THREE THERE ARE OTHERS
IN THE PRESS ONE ZERO SEVEN
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
YOU'RE MEMBERS THIS IS MARK
SMITH A MAP THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GUIDANCE FOURTEEN
THIRTY ASIAN WANT TO SAY THAT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT BUT WE IF YOU
LOVE ME THE ABILITY TO MAKE ONE
THAT WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
AMERICAN RIVER SYSTEM SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THE WATERSHED. THE
BEST BILL IT IS THE FACT
LARGEST RHETORICA THE
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU THANK YOU
THIS IS NOW. THANK YOU. HAVE
ANOTHER LINE IN SUPPORT THIS
LINE SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINES OF. HI MARKETS YREKA
RICHET PROBABLY THE NEAREST
NEIGHBOR TO THE- GET SOME OF
THE AIR AT AND A LIFELONG
DESERT RESIDENTS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT OUR COMMUNITY
IS ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SEEING
THAT HAPPEN. FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU A ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE- ON THE PHONE
LINES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU NO
OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME OKAY THERE'S A SOMEONE IS
PRESENT IN THE CHAMBERS AND
WANTS TO STATE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. START MY APOLOGIES PUBLIC
GUYS AGAIN I'VE LEFT A COUPLE
GROUPS OUT ALSO WONDERING-
REGISTER SUPPORT FROM. THE
WATER SAID RESEARCH AND
TRAINING CENTER- WOMEN'S
CORPORATION THE TWENTY COUNTY
TRINITY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SHASTA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR MARK. RICKER THANK
YOU. WE WILL NOW ASK- THERE IS-
REGISTERED OPPOSITION WE HAVE
BOB READ AND IS THE MARTIN AND-
LAST THOSE TWO INDIVIDUALS TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO PROVIDE
THEIR TWO MINUTE OF TESTIMONY
THEY ARE TESTIFYING BOB IT'S IN
PERSON- IS MARTIN VIA TELEPHONE.
THE PHYSICS GORDON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO. STATE MY
APPRECIATION FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO SAVE AND
PUT ON A JACKET AND TIE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A NUMBER OF
WEEKS- I REPRESENT- THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE LISTED. IN
THE ANALYSIS IN OPPOSITION. LET
ME FIRST TO BE LAID ON THEIR
BEHALF OF THAT- THEY COULD KERR
WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
SUPPORTERS THAT WATERSHED
RESTORATION FORCE MANAGEMENT.
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA. THAT SAID WE DON'T
BELIEVE THE BILL IS NECESSARY-
STATE AGENCIES CAN AND HAVE
BEEN PARTICIPATING WITH LOCAL
AGENCIES NON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES ON RESTORATION FOREST
THINNING AND MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS- THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR
IN ABOUT A REGION WE BELIEVE
THAT THE- PARTICULAR. CALLING
OUT OR- IN THIS BILL- THE
SHASTA IN WHISKEY TOWN
RESERVOIRS AN ORAL RESERVOIRS
ARE CURIOUS THAT FAST FOR
EXAMPLE THE SHASTA AND
WHISKEYTOWN RESERVOIRS LIE
WHOLLY WITHIN THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE LANDS AND OF NATIONAL
FOREST SERVICE LANDS SO THE
STATE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED
BY THIS BILL WOULD BE UNLIKELY
TO AFFECT PROJECTS IN THOSE
AREAS WITHOUT COOPERATION WITH
THOSE FEDERAL AGENCIES WHICH
AGAIN THEY CAN DO TODAY- WE'RE
ALSO CONCERNED AS WATER
PURVEYORS WITH HOUSING THIS
ADMINISTRATION WITHIN THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
WE REMIND THE LEGISLATURE THAT
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS THE
STATE BOARD HAS BEEN PROVIDED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PORTIONS OF
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT AT FOR THE URBAN
WATER CONSERVATION AND. THE
DROUGHT IN DROUGHT RESPONSE
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE BAY DELTA
WATER QUALITY CONTROL PLAN PLAN
UPDATE FOR THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUNDS
FOR THE WATER LOW INCOME RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THERE PLATE
IS FULL AS WATER PURVEYORS WERE
CONCERNED- WITH PLACING THIS
PROGRAM THERE AND ADDING ON TO
IT- WERE WILLING AND APPRECIATE
THE AUTHORS OFFER TO WORK WITH
HIM IN THE SUPPORTERS- TODAY
THOUGH WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE HAVE- ONE OTHER
WITNESS THAT WILL BE TESTIFYING
VIA TELEPHONE IS MARTIN. THE
SHEER FUN. MODERATOR GARCIA.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES DECEMBER
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE I AM IN THE
MARKET YOU KNOW YOUR FUN I
PLUGGED IN THE TO BLOOM DECIDED
TO BRING NEW REPORTER FOR
WATERSHED PLANNING FOR THE
HEADWATERS. WORK HARDER CORD
FISCAL YEAR FUN BUT WE'RE NOT
IN AGREEMENT. WITH HIS APPROACH
YES. THE MET YESTERDAY TO
DISCUSS DIFFERENT. I BRING.
FROM THIRD BUT DO IT AB TWENTY
SIX NINE THREE WHAT'S THE DATE
INCLUDING THE IN FIFTY. SEVEN
FIVE. AND THE COW INDIAN. LINE
BUT THE LETTERS AND I COULD ON
THEIR BEHALF. WE DON'T THE NEED
TO A NEW GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY
WITH ALL THE ASSOCIATED. BANKS
AND THE WAY IT IS ONE OF THE
PLANET I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THE WAR AFFECTED FASTER. THAN
PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT.
FOR THE DCADES OLD WORK THAT
EXISTING COLLABORATIVE
WATERSHED AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ALREADY DOING
IN. AND AROUND THIS REGION. WE
ARE VERY ABOUT THE GUY
STRUCTURE THAT WE'VE HEARD FOR
DOES NOT INCLUDE PEOPLE FROM
THE EIGHTIES AND THE WATER
PLANNING UP. ONE OF REPORT
ORDINARY DELIBERATE DIGITAL NOW
WHEN. THANK YOU VERY. PARTS
WITH FUNDING RESILIENT. ONE OF
THE HEARING ABOUT THE SERVICE.
THE BILL A LARGE PHONE BY THREE
TO JUST LIKE THE STRUCTURE THE
BIG LAW MANAGED GROUP AND OTHER
COLLABORATIVE IN THE REGION.
THIS AREA HOME THE SEVERAL
RECOGNIZED AND MANY INDIGENOUS
TRIBES BUT THE BILL ONLY GIVE
ONE REGIONAL PARK WHERE FIFTY
SB AT THE END BY THREE TABLE
AND THERE IS NO SUCH REGIONAL
RIVAL HERE FIFTY. I UNDERSTAND
VALUE OF A REGIONALLY SPECIFIC
WATERSHED PLAN THE TAP WATER I
AGREE WITH THE AMERICAN RIVER
ADVOCATE. JUST WONDERED HOW
COME OTHER RELATIVES AND CAN'T
GET THE SPECIAL GOOD NEWS.
HOWEVER OTHER THAN CREATING THE
STATE AGENCY. I DON'T YET
UNDERSTAND HOW THE BILL CREATE
SOMETHING BETTER THAN THE
STATE'S HANDS RATED THAT DENTAL
PLAN IN UPPER. IN THIS PART OF
THE REGION. AND HOW ARE YOU
PLAN WILL BUILD ON THE BECAUSE
IT CAN AFFECT FINALLY THIS
POLICY IS BIG SUPPOSED THE HEAD
OF BOXING OUT THE RESULT. OF
THE STATE MANDATED ASSESSMENT
OF THE REGION DISADVANTAGED AT
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITY.
WATERGATE HOW DOES THIS PLAN
THE CORPORATE THE BAND IT. AND
OTHER THIRD COMMUNITIES. I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BLOOM
IN THE BILL THROUGH THE DARK
ARTS AND- WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
ONE WEAPON IT. THANK THANK YOU
WELL I YOU FOR A- THE IN THE
QUEUE WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE- HAVE THEM- COME FORWARD
AND SPEAK TO AN OPPOSITION.
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITIONS.
THANK YOU ON THE PHONE LINES WE
HAVE LINE THIRTY FOUR AND IF
THERE ARE OTHERS PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THREE FOR YOUR
LINE OF THE OPEN. HE CREEK
TURNS OUT THEY HAVE TO BE
CALIFORNIA FOR THREE
ASSOCIATION WERE IN OPPOSITION
MINOR. TO THE COMMON FOR THE
CURE FUND. THANK YOU. NO OTHERS
IN Q. AT THIS TIME WE WILL
BRING THAT BACK- TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. I DON'T KNOW IF
I ASKED IS THERE ANYONE IN
PERSON- WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. CNN
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OF A
QUESTIONS COMMENTS AND OR-
MOTIONS. QUESTIONS A LECTURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. MOST OF
MY QUESTIONS ACTUALLY WERE
ANSWERED IN YOUR OPENING AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT I WILL BE
OPPOSING THE BILL TODAY- WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT I DO APPRECIATE.
THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
WATERSHEDS AND DOING MORE WORK
THERE BUT THE SUBJECT OF THIS
BILL NEEDS MORE. ROBUST
DISCUSSION NEXT WEEK NEXT YEAR
TO GIVE OUR LOCALS AT OUR
STAKEHOLDERS OPPORTUNITY TO
TRULY ENGAGE AND NOT TO JUST BE
AT THE TABLE TO HAVE DISCUSSION
BUT TO BE VOTING MEMBERS TO. TO
SUGGEST THAT THE SIERRA FIND
AND THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
HAVE BEEN OING THIS WORK.
SHOULD JUST BE ADVISORY I THINK
IS. WRONG JUST ANYWAY SO. THERE
ARE EXISTING PROJECTS FOR THE
WATERSHED IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
WATER HAS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
DOING GREAT WORK AND I DO WANT
TO CONCLUDE THAT THIS
CONSERVATION AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS LOCATED AND
WORKING IN THE REGION. ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS GREAT WORK I
URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE NO
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. SURE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THAT'S WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- MISTER
BLOOM I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY BUT I'M IN A RESERVE
MY RIGHT TO NOT IN THE FUTURE
AND I WENT ONLINE PART OF MY
COMMENTS WITH- MS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOLLY. TOGETHER THE TWO
OF US REPRESENT 23% OF THE LAND
MASS IN CALIFORNIA YET WE HAVE
NO REPRESENTATION IN THIS NEW.
STRUCTURE THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND. THE ORGANIZATIONS ON
THE GROUND HAVE NO
REPRESENTATION. AND THAT IS
SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE- IT GOING
FORWARD. YOU KNOW IT IS THE
WATER FOR THE STATE THE BULK OF
THE WATER FOR THE STATE
COMMENTS FROM OUR WATERSHEDS
AND YET THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR. FOR SEAT AT
THE TABLE AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT MOVING FORWARD WE FIND A
WAY TO RESOLVE THAT RESULT THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MEMBER
IN YOUR QUESTIONS YOUR COMMENTS.
OF WHICH RUBIO THANK YOU-
MISTER HELLO MY ALSO- SHARE THE
SENTIMENTS I WOULD NOT- I'M
VERY BIG ON THE WATER
ESPECIALLY THE THANK EVER
VALLEY THERE THAT WE HAVE MANY
ISSUES AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IF A BILL LIKE THIS GOES BY
THAT THE FOLKS THAT ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED IN INVOLVED
SHOULD BE PART OF THE PROCESS.
I WOULD NOT LIKE- SOMEBODY TO
TELL ME IN MY AREA- YOU KNOW
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE WITHOUT
ENGAGING MY LOCAL WATER
FO'C'SLE AB I YOU KNOW DID
HAVE- THIS DISCUSSION WITH YOU-
BUT I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT IN
THE FUTURE FOR GOING TO GOING
TO OTHER PEOPLE'S DISTRICTS
THAT WE NEED TO INCLUDE FIRST A
MEMBER AND SECONDLY THE FOLKS
ON THE GROUND SO. I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT AGAIN
RESERVE THE RIGHT MYSELF TO NOT
SUPPORTED ON THE FLOOR BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S CRUCIAL THAT IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER ON WATER ISSUES THAT
WE ALL ARE AT TEAM AS OPPOSED
TO DOING YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE IT'S BEEN AND
FINALS AND REALLY STEPPING ON
OTHER FOLKS. TOLLS WHEN THOSE
FOLKS YOU REALLY NEED TO BE
ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS YOU KNOW
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE CRITICAL-
THE HOW CRITICAL WATER AND I
SAID- SURE TO OUR AND I IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BENEFIT
FROM THE POLICIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I DON'T WANT
THAT- FIGHT TAKEN. IF YOU WERE.
WE ALL. THE YOU KNOW ADAGE OF
WITH FOR DURING WATER FIGHTING
I DON'T WANT TO FIGHT WITH MY
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOLKS
ANYMORE I WANT US TO BE
PARTNERS. BECAUSE MY
COMMUNITIES DEPEND ON NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SON MEMBER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. SEE NO MICROPHONES
RAISED- MISTER BLOOM WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS ANY OF THE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS OR CONCERNS RAISED.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL OF THE COMMENTS
INCLUDING THOSE OF THAT ACCOUNT
AND- FROM OPPOSITION. THIS IS
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS
ALL ABOUT IT'S AN ITERATIVE
PROCESS- AS YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD ME SAY AS THE FOR. THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THANK- WE
WILL BE MAKING THIS PLANS MORE
INCLUSIVE WE WILL BE MEETING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS WE'RE NOT.
DONE YET WE'RE NOT AT THE
FINISH LINE AND I RESPECT THAT
YOU'RE RIGHT TO WITHHOLD YOUR
MOBILE- AS FIVE OR A- ABOUT
DIFFERENTLY WHEN THE BILL COMES
TO THE FLOOR- FOR NOW YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT THAT I WILL WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. AND BASED ON
MY OWN PERSONAL HISTORY- I'D
PROBABLY NOT IF YOU ARE AWARE
THAT. I WAS THE CHAIR OF THE
SANTA MONICA BAY RESTORATION
COMMISSION FOR MANY YEARS AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IT'S A
STAKEHOLDER. A GROUP IT AT-
OVERSEAS DISTRIBUTION OF
FUNDING IN A REGIONAL.
WATERSHED AND IT'S A VERY VERY
EFFECTIVE MODEL AND IT'S
EFFECTIVE BECAUSE IT'S
INCLUSIVE. AND SO YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON MAKING
THIS MORE CONCLUSIVE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND- I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DERIVE A-
THANK YOU IS THERE A MOTION TO
MOVE THIS BILL WITH THOSE OF
THE TO PAY WRITTEN A COOPER.
SHE PLOY ISN'T MAKE MOST
REFUSING THE SECOND THANK YOU
FOR CLOSING REMARKS- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA I THE BORDER
GARCIA HI. MEGHAN DALLY. MEGHAN
DALLY NO BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO
FLORA. JUNE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA. GLORIA GLORIA
I. KALRA KALRA HI LEVINE LEVINE
I MATHIS. MATHIS NO BLANCA
RUBIO. BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS
WOULD WOOD I. THE VOTE IS SEVEN
TO THREE THANK YOU WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
WHO WILL BE COMING BACK AFTER
PRESENTING BILLS LIKE THIS WILL
BE PRESENTATION- WE HAVE- ONE
WITH TWO BILLS LEFT OF A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND JUST
WANTED KNOWLEDGE OF. IT WAS
VERY GOOD JOB OF MODERATING A
GOOD JOB ONE FOR THE RULES. AND
SO WILL BE OUT SHORTLY- WITH-
WITH THIS AGENDA- MISTER
RIVERS. WE EIGHTEEN QUALIFY
ITEM TWELVE MAYBE THIRTEEN OH
FIVE. I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TO YOU DO HAVE
TO INVADE JUST TESTIFYING VIA
TELEPHONE WILL GET THEM- READY
TO GO AND AS WELL AS CALLERS-
WHO WILL BE- SUPPORTING A NAME
STATE. IN THE NAME OUR DISHES
IN SUPPORT THERE'S ALSO A TWO
INDIVIDUALS THAT- ONE
INDIVIDUAL THE WILL BE
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION SO MAKE
SURE AT THAT THEY'RE AWARE AND
READY TO GO. ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MISTER RIVAS. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR THE MORNING
COLLEAGUES GREAT TO SEE YOU
EVEN IF IT IS THE BACKS OF YOUR
HEADS IN THIS. SET UP BUT IT IS
ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE YOU GUYS. I
LIKE THE FIRST THING- THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL
THE COORDINATION WITH. SO OTHER
OF A THE COMMITTEES IN THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
NATURAL RESOURCES JUDICIARY.
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS. KNOWS A LOT OF WORK
SO THANK YOU- BUT I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
ZERO ZERO FIVE THE- EXPEDITED.
DAM SAFETY FOR SILICON VALLEY
ACT. SO IT'S LAST TIME I WILL
SAY THAT. TITLE BUT THIS BILL
IS AN URGENCY BILL- AND SEEKS
TO ENACT CHANGES IN STATE LAW
CHANGES. THIS YEAR. TO HELP
FACILITATE THE EXPEDITED
REHABILITATION OR SEISMIC
RETROFITS TO ANDERSON DAM. THIS
ISSUE AND DAM CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
TO THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT
INTO THE LARGER. SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND THE SILICON VALLEY
REGION. MY FIRST THIS IS A
DIFFERENT ISSUE. THIS BILL
INVOLVED A LOCAL DAMAGE TO
MENTION THE ANDERSON DAM. AT
THIS DAM WAS BUILT IN NINETEEN
FIFTY IS LOCATED IN SOUTHERN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. IT HAS A
CAPACITY OF NEARLY NINETY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET IS THE
LARGEST RESERVOIR IN THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA. AND IS A
CRITICAL PART OF THE SILICON
VALLEY'S DRINKING WATER SUPPLY.
I MENTIONED THAT THE DAM WAS
BUILT IN NINETEEN FIFTY. AND IT
WAS BUILT TO THE SAFETY
STANDARDS OF THAT TIME. BUT AS
WE NOW KNOW THE DAM WAS
CONSTRUCTED ALONG TO EARTHQUAKE
FAULT LINES. THE CALAVERAS
FAULT WHICH IS A MAJOR BRANCH
OF THE SAN ANDREAS FAULT SYSTEM
AND THE DAM ALSO SITS DIRECTLY
ABOVE THE COYOTE CREEK PAULINE.
SECOND THIS ISSUE IS A REGIONAL
ONE AS I STATED THIS DAM IS THE
LARGEST RESERVOIR IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND IT'S A
CRITICAL PART OF THE SILICON
VALLEY. THE SILICON VALLEY
DRINKING WATER SUPPLY. WHEN
ANDERSON DAM WAS COMPLETED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WAS A VERY PRODUCTIVE.
AGRICULTURAL REGION WITH A
POPULATION OF TWO HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND. AND AS WE ALL
KNOW NOW THE CARD COUNTY. IT'S
AN INTERNATIONAL HUB OF THE
TECH ECONOMY WITH A POPULATION
NEARLY TWO MILLION. THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE THE COUNTY SEAT IS
CURRENTLY THE THIRD LARGEST
CITY IN CALIFORNIA THE TENTH
LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY IN TERMS
OF POPULATION. AND THIS AND THE
SCENT OF A REGION HOME OF THE
SILICON VALLEY IS A VITAL
CONTRIBUTOR TO OUR STATE AND
NATIONAL ECONOMY. AND IS EDISON
DAM ISSUE POSES SOME SERIOUS
PROBLEMS FOR THE REGION. THE
DAM HAS SOME SERIOUS STRUCTURAL
INTEGRITY ISSUES. IN THE EVENT
OF AN EARTHQUAKE THE BRIDGE OF
THE DAM AT FULL CAPACITY WOULD
BE CATASTROPHIC. IN THAT
SCENARIO IS PREDICTED THAT FROM
THE SIDE OF THE DAM. FLOODING
WOULD EXTEND MORE THAN THIRTY
MILES NORTHWEST TO THE SAM
CISCO BAY. IMPACT IN THE CITIES
OF SAN JOSE SANTA CLARA.
SUNNYVALE IN MILPITAS. AND
FLOODING WOULD ALSO EXTEND
ANOTHER FORTY MILES SOUTHEAST
TO MONTEREY BAY. IMPACT IN THIS
IS A MORGAN HILL GILROY IN
WATSONVILLE. AND WHAT BRINGS US
HERE TODAY WHY DID YOU DO THIS
BILL. THIS IS A DISTRICT ISSUE.
WITH REGIONAL IMPACTS THAT
REQUIRE IMMEDIATE STATE ACTION.
AGAIN THIS BILL AB THREE ZERO
ZERO EIGHT IS AN URGENCY BILL.
IT'S AN URGENCY BILL BECAUSE ON
FEBRUARY TWENTIETH THE FEDERAL
ENERGY REGULATORY COMMISSION
BURKE. ISSUED A DAM SAFETY
DIRECTIVE REQUIRING THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT OR
VALLEY WATER. ASSET TO FULLY
DRAW DOWN ANDERSON DOWN
STARTING OCTOBER FIRST OF THIS
YEAR. NOW ACCORDING TO THE
FEDERAL ORDER THIS DIRECTIVE IS
UNAVOIDABLE. BECAUSE BASED ON
THE NEW INFORMATION REGARDING
THE DAM SEISMIC VULNERABILITIES
THE DAM SAFETY RISK IS
UNACCEPTABLY HIGH. ACCORDING TO
THE COMMISSION THE RISK AT THIS
PROJECT TO DOWNSTREAM LIFE AND
PROPERTY IS EXTREME. A
CATASTROPHIC EIGHT CATASTROPHIC
DAM FAILURE COULD POTENTIALLY
AFFECT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE. AS A RESULT SUCH OF
THESE DECISIONS MUST BE MADE
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY BE THE
PARAMOUNT FACTOR. IN A LETTER
TO THE WATER DISTRICT ISSUE
WITH THIS DIRECTED THE FEDERAL
COMMISSION ENCOURAGE THE
pDISTRICT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL HASTE. ALL HASTE TO
DESIGN IT SECURE THE NECESSARY
PERMITS AND COMPLETE THE DESIGN
FOR THE REHABILITATION OR
RETROFITS TO THIS. THIS FELLOW
DIRECTED TO BEGIN DRAINING THE
LARGEST RESERVOIR IN THE COUNTY
OF SANTA CLARA POSES MANY MANY
CHALLENGES. DRAINAGE WILL
SEVERELY REDUCE WATER RESERVES
GROUNDWATER BASINS IN THE
COUNTY COULD BE IMPACTED
INCLUDING IN THE SOUTHERN SAN
JOSE MORGAN HILL SAN MARTINE IN
THE CITY OF GILROY. AND FOR A
STATE PRONE TO DROUGHT THIS IS
A PROBLEM. THIS DRAINAGE WILL
ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS
THE FISH WILDLIFE AND
ENVIRONMENTS. AGAIN THIS
URGENCY BILL SEEKS TO EXPEDITE
PERMITTING AND CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE CONSTRUCTION
IMPROVEMENTS TO ADDRESS IN DOWN.
IF YOU CONSIDER THAT THE WATER
DISTRICT INITIATED THIS SEISMIC
RETROFIT PROJECT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IF THE DISTRICT
IS ABLE TO USE THE MECHANISMS
IN THIS URGENCY BILL. THEY
SHOULD BE IN A STRONG POSITION
TO CONSTRUCT THIS NEW DAM AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND IN
DOING SO IT WOULD REDUCE THE
DURATION OF WATER SUPPLY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT WILL PROVIDE FOR
THE LONG TERM SAFETY. OF THIS
REGION. AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
MAYOR MORGAN HILL RICH CONSTANT
TIME. AND KURT LEWIN BURGER
WITH VALLEY WATER HURT- WILL
ALSO BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THIS BILL. AND WITH THAT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MS RIVER SAID THEY
WILL BE TESTIFYING VIA
TELEPHONE THE- HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH TO. PROVIDE TESTIMONY- TO
THIS MEASURE. PLEASE OPPOSE THE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
RICHARD COTTON TIE AND I AM THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF MORGAN
HILL. RGD UP FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IS LOCATED
DIRECTLY BELOW ANDERSON DAM
RESERVOIR. IF THE DAM WERE TO
FAIL WHEN IT IS AT FULL
CAPACITY AT THIRTY FOOT WALL OF
WATER WHICH SWEEP THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY IN FIVE TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES. AND THAT'S JUST THE
BEGINNING OF THE DEVASTATION
THAT WOULD RUN NORTH TO SILICON
VALLEY AND STOP THE MONTEREY
BAY. THE EARTHQUAKE FAULTS ONE
LOCATED ABOUT A MILE AWAY FROM
THE DAM. AND THE OTHER DIRECTLY
UNDERNEATH THE DAM ARE NOT
DORMANT. IN ACT WE HAD A FOUR
POINT OH EARTHQUAKE EARLIER
THIS YEAR. IMAGINE WONDERING IF
EVERY TIME THE EARTH SHAKES IF
A THIRTY FOOT WALL OF WATER
WHAT HEADING YOUR WAY. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT GETTING THIS
REMOVED AND REPLACED AT QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE IS A VERY HIGH
PRIORITY FOR EVERYONE WHO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT STATE.
THAT WHY THE CITY OF MORGAN
HILL STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IN ADDITION TO PROTECTING LIVES
AND PROPERTY A WITH. IF I
RECALL RESTORE PRECIOUS WATER
SUPPLY YOU'RE NOT JUST MY
DUTIES BUT ALSO A DOZEN OTHERS
TO OUT TO THE CAR ABOUT. A FEW
MONTHS AGO I WENT TO WASHINGTON
DC TO MEET WITH CONGRESO MEANT
O'LOUGHLIN AND THE OTHER THREE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO
REPRESENT OUR COUNTY. THEY ARE
ALL WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE
THE FEDERATION LEADERS DO NOT.
HI THIS PROJECT UP IN RED TAPE
FOR YEARS. I HAVE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER READ THIS TO A
CHECKING UP THE BATTLE IN
SACRAMENTO TO MAKE SURE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES ITS
PART TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND A WALK THE BY. BUT THE TWO
MILLION PEOPLE A SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. WITH THE CHAIR NUMBER I
THANK YOU FOR GATHERING IN
COMMITTEE TODAY. HERE THIS BILL
AMID A PANDEMIC. THE WORK THAT
YOU ARE DOING IS IMPORTANT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO IT
EIGHTY THREE THERE THERE ARE A
LOT. AND I VOTE ON EIGHTY THREE
ZERO ZERO FIVE WILL EXPEDITE
THE PROJECT. THAT WILL PROTECT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO LIVE AND WORK IN THE IN
ADDITION DOWN. ON ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF MORGAN HILL I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU- NEXT THE- WITNESS
PROVIDE IN TWO MINUTES THE
TESTIMONY. THEY'RE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KURT
ONE BURGER AND I CARE ABOUT THE
VIRAL SERVICES MANAGER WITH
CENTER VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
ALSO KNOWN AS VALLEY WATER AB
THIRTY OH FIVE COLLECTED IDEA
TO BE A FIVE WEEK RETROFIT
PROJECT TO FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLAR REMOVAL AND
REPLACEMENT OF THE EXISTING DAM
WHICH IS DONALD FAILURE DURING
A LARGE EARTHQUAKE. THE PROJECT
WILL INCLUDE DOWNSTREAM
PROGRAMS FOR FLOOD CONTROL AND
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT THE LOCAL
CREATED REFLECT FIVE THOUSAND
GOOD PAYING JOBS BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MAKING THE
PROJECT WILL FIND ECONOMIC
STIMULUS THE PERMITS ARE ISSUED
EXPEDITIOUSLY. CONSTRUCTED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THE CURRENT DâN
ABOUT THE ABOUT NINETY THOUSAND
ACRE FEET IT IS THE LARGEST
RESERVOIR TANK THERE COUNTY
PLUS DRINKING WATER FOR SILICON
VALLEY. DURING THE- WATER THAN
THE SMALL LOOK CAN'T RELEASE.
WITH IN THE SELLING THE
RESERVOIR DESPITE FIND
PRESCRIPTION IT AT 35% AFTER
THE LAST. BEGAN AT. OKAY DECREE
THESE LOOK THAT WOULD GO DRIVE.
DAM OPERATE. CENTER
CONSTRUCTION DAMAGE FROM. YOUR
CALLED HABITAT FIFTY INCLUDE
SALMON STEEL AND- WHAT THE DAM
OF. DE AND BY. HERE ARE
COMPLETED THAT. FOR FISHERIES
WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
OVER THE CURRENT CONDITION. AB
THIRTY THERE ARE FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
WILDLIFE AND STATE WATER BOARD
COMPLETE EARNING WITHIN A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. IF OUR
WATER MEET CERTAIN
PREREQUISITES INCLUDING FOR.
SUBMITTING A COMPLETE PERMIT
APPLICATION SECOND SUBMITTING A
COMPLETE APPLICATION FOR A
CHANGE IN WATER RIGHT NEEDED
FOR THE FINAL FLOWS. AND
FINALLY COMPLETING THE
CERTIFICATIONS REQUIRED. THE
CLERK. EARLY COUPLE. WITH THE
STATE. HAVE BEEN ONGOING DEBATE
THIRTEEN AND I'M TESTIFIED TO
THE EIGHTEEN. VALLEY WATER NOW
ME SEVERAL TIMES MONTH WITH
STATE FEDERAL PERMITTING A- BY
THE TIME FOR ME TO. ARE
SUBMITTED LET BEEN MANY OF
REVIEW AND DISCUSS.AS WELL AS
NUMEROUS PUBLIC MEETINGS TO
EXPLAIN THE PROJECT AND ITS
IMPACT STAKEHOLDERS. IN
FEBRUARY THE FEDERAL ENERGY
REGULATORY COMMISSION. ORDERED
VALLEY WATER TO BEGIN DRAINING
RESERVOIR BY OCTOBER OF THIS
YEAR AND A START CONSTRUCTION
OF A NEW LARGER DâN OUTLET
TUNNEL. AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
DRAIN THE RESERVOIR REDUCE
BEGAN TAKING RISKS BUT IT
INCREASES REST WATER SUPPLY
LIABILITIES SILICON VALLEY AND
TO THE ENVIRONMENT. AB THIRTY
OH FIVE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
PERMITTING DEADLINE WILL HELP
KEEP EVERYONE INCLUDING VALLEY
WATER APPROPRIATELY FOCUSED ON
DELIVERING THE CRITICAL BENEFIT
BUT PROJECT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. EXPEDITING ANDERSON
EXPEDITE PUBLIC SAFETY
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HAPPENS WATER
SUPPLY RELIABILITY AND ECONOMIC
STIMULUS. ON BEHALF VALLEY
WATER I HEARD YOU'RE EITHER ON
AB THIRTY OH FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO A-
MODERATE TO HAVE ANY. AND FOLKS
CALLING IN. ON THE PHONE LINE
TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE. THAT NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. THANK YOU WE HAVE
SEVERAL ON CUE RIGHT NOW WILL
GO TO LINE FORTY THREE FOUR
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
FORTY THREE MAY BE A NEW.
ROBERT GORE FROM THE COOPER
GROUP A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- ON BEHALF OF
SAN JOSE WITH WATER WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS. YOUR
PERSON LABOR. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THANK YOU. BAKER LINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN HIRE
WORKERS ALL CONGOLESE
LEADERSHIP GROUP MORE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AB THIRTY ZERO FIVE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TIME.
NEXT CALL LINE EIGHTY TWO
AIRLINERS OPEN. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRIS ANDERSON ON THE
APPLICATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ANY UP LOTS OF
HIDING WITH CALIFORNIA FLEE
TELEVISA THIRTY ASIAN IN THE
CORNER DRIVE A- THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JENNINGS MET
JACKIE HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALL WILL WORK.
DO YOU MIND FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIVE ZERO. CAPTION MISTER
CHAIR MARK FREDERICK ON BEHALF
OF THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACE ABILITY FOR THANK YOU.
YEAH LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS STAND READY AND I REPRESENT
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES LOCAL ONE OH ONE WE
ARE AT THE STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE. THANK YOU
LINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS NATALIE MAC
SAID HERE ON BEHALF OF THAT
THAT'S WHY WE OPEN SPACE IT'S
JUST DIFFERENT SUPPORT OF AB
THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE. IF YOU
ARE LAST LINE AND SUPPORTERS
LINE EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AS CHAIR
MEMBERS OF TWENTY THIS LOUIS
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
GILROY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW FOR THE
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
MODERATOR WE HAVE- ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S THE REGISTERED
TO TESTIFY VIA TELEPHONE THAT
OF REDLANDS CALIFORNIA DROUGHT.
LESTER'S ANYONE. HERE
PRESIDENT- TO- PROVIDE SUPPORT.
FOR THE BILL WILL BELONG TO THE
OPPOSITION- WHICH MAKES ANYONE
YOUR SUPPORT SEE NO ONE. WANT
TO THE OPPOSITION- WITNESS-
THAT- REGGIE COLLINS CALIFORNIA.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
DISREGARD THAT I'M A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH CALIFORNIA
DROUGHT IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
THREE ZERO FIVE I GOT THAT WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE
TO SOLVE THE STATE'S RESOURCE
ISSUES WHILE BALANCING THE
NEEDS OF. A FISH WATER IN
PEOPLE WE PRIDE OURSELVES ON
WORKING COOPERATIVELY THE FIRST
GROUP OF PARTNERS AND DO NOT
TAKE OPPOSITION CENTERS LIGHTLY
HOWEVER AFTER SPEAKING WITH THE
ON HIS OFFICE AFTER YOUR
INITIAL LETTER OF OPPOSITION
AND TALKING WITH SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT WE'VE
DECIDED FORMALLY SPEAKING
OPPOSITION EIGHT EIGHT THREE
ZERO ZERO FIVE. THE FOLLOWING
REASONS. CORRECT AND THE THEIR
STANDARD LEGAL RIGHT DE WRAPPED
UP A PROJECT NAKED. TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY. HOWEVER I
REPRESENT A WELL WE'RE NOW BY
THE COMMITTEE. I WE RECOGNIZE
THE OTHER DOES AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE FIFTY PROSPECT THAT
LATE. WITHOUT AND AT THE SHORT.
EIGHTY THREE THEIR THEIR FIVE
THAT THE DANGERS PRECEDENT FOR
ALL FUTURE DAMAGE OCCURRED
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
APPLYING THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES AND THE STATE BOARD TO
HEAR TO SHORTEN TIMELINES
EXHAUSTED NOTIFICATION. AND
UNIQUE APPEALS PROPERTY
ULTIMATELY DOES NOT ALLOW THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCIES. THE
TIME AND SPACE NEEDED TO
ADEQUATELY PROTECT. PUBLIC
TRUST RESOURCES. THE WATER
DISTRICT ISN'T UNMATCHED
PARTNER CONSERVE ON AND ARE
THERE FOR NOW CREDIBLE ADVOCATE
BELIEVE ACT ON THOSE PUBLIC
TRUST RESOURCES. WE STRONGLY
DISAGREE AT THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL AT IMPLEMENTED BY THE
WATER DISTRICT WILL BE
NECESSARY TO ADEQUATELY PROTECT
LISTED FISH AND WILDLIFE
SPECIES ESPECIALLY BETTER LIKE
AND- CENTRAL CALIFORNIA COAST
STILL HAD. NEARLY TWENTY YEARS
THE FISHERIES AND AQUATIC
HABITAT COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT PARTIES
WHICH INCLUDE CAL TROUT HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR ADEQUATE STREET
WHILE. WE'RE STILL HADN'T HAD
AGREEMENT A BROTHER WILDLIFE'S
ARRIVAL COUNTY CREEK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH DEMOCRAT ALEC
WATER WATER DISTRICT.
PERSONALLY THE ONE IF YOU COULD
NOT HERE THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE FEDERAL PARTY I FELT THE
ANY OF THE SENATE TERMS OR
IMPLEMENT ANY STREAM FORGOTTEN
OR HABITAT IMPROVEMENT. AGREED
TO BY THE FAITH IN THE SHOWING
PARTY. AB THREE THEIR THEIR
FIVE WOULD LEGALIZE THING YOU
ALLOWED UNILATERAL DECISION
MAKING. AND ACTION PROCESS BY
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT THAT IT
NEARLY LED TO THE LOCAL
EXTINCTION. OF STEEL AND CARRY
CREEK ALREADY. THE SEVEN NOT
IMPORTANT OPPOSED THE THREE
ZERO FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK OVER THE FALLEN IN THE
STEP DOWN THANK YOU WE'LL ASK-
MODERATOR NOW TO OPEN THE QUEUE
THE- CALLS MAY BE REPLACE FOR.
OPPOSITION I TO THIS MEASURE
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
PLEASE. Q. IF YOUR POSITION AS
AN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THESE ARE ALL LOCAL FIRST
THE LINE NINETY FIVE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M
ACTUALLY. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL MICHAEL
ATTY THE OUT. OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE YOUR
LINE OF THE. I WOULD GO AND
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION FOR THE WATERLOO PKO
THE RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT THANK YOU. LINE NINETY
FOUR NINE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS GERRY WELLING
DIRECTOR OF WATER CHIU
UTILITIES CITY OF SANTA CLARA
ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE AND THE
EXPEDITED DAM SAFETY FOR
SILICON VALLEY ACT. THAT WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IF THERE ARE ANY OTHERS. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NO
FOR OTHERS. THE COMMENTS FROM
THE PHONE AT THIS TIME THE
MODERATOR WE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND- QUESTIONS-
FOR THE OTHER ROOMS POWER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK OF A
COLLEAGUES ON THE RUN RIVAS-
FOR BRING THIS BILL FOR IT AND
I'M PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR. OF
THIS BILL AND THE REALITY IS
THE DAMAGE BASED UPON THE
FAILURE OF THE ANDERSON DAM IS
NOT SIMPLY HYPOTHETICAL. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN THE HEART
OF MY DISTRICT IN DOWNTOWN SAN
JOSE AREA. OVER SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF DAMAGE OCCURRED IN
AROUND FIVE HUNDRED HOMES
AROUND INHABITABLE BASED UPON A
SPILLOVER OF THE ANDERSON DAM-
NOT A CATASTROPHIC- THAT WOULD
OCCUR. SOON TO ME AS LIKE A
BAND SO WE KNOW THAT THE DAMAGE
THAT CAN BE DONE. VERY MUCH
REAL AND THAT THE AS WAS NOTED.
I IN THE TESTIMONY FOR THE FOR
GOVERNMENT'S REALLY TO USE ON
OUR REGION. FORCING OUR HAND TO
QUICKLY EXPEDITE THE DAM
RETROFIT AJ. ADDITIONALLY
PROVISIONS WAITED TO SEE WHAT
AN EXTRA JUDICIAL REVIEW WERE
REMOVED- AND SO YOU'LL STILL
GET AN APPROPRIATE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND JUDICIAL
REVIEW PROCESS. NOW THE
PROVISIONS REGARDING THE BEST
VALUE CONTRACTOR CAN IN. IN
SOME SITUATIONS. RATE PROBLEMS
REGARD THE CALL OF WORK THAT ME
A CO. ON AND SO. THE FACT THAT-
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
PROHIBITS A BEST A CONTRACTOR.
FROM BEING PRE QUALIFIED OR
SHORTLISTED UNLESS THE CONTRACT
PROVIDES ENFORCEABLE COMMITMENT
TO THE DISTRICT OF THE
CONTRACTOR. AND IS
SUBCONTRACTORS EVERY TEAR WOULD
USE A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE FOR ALL THE WORK IN
THE PROJECT. IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND OF COURSE THAT
THAT PROHIBITION DOESN'T APPLY.
A DOLLY WATER WITH A CONTRACTOR
OF ENTERED INTO A P. LA AND
SUDDENLY IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT NOT JUST TO TALK TO
WORKERS. DURING SURE THE
QUALITY OF THE PROJECT WILL BE
SUCH OF WHAT A PART OF THIS
SIZE AND NATURE. DESERVE AND
WAS THIS PROJECT IS DONE WERE
HOPE IT'LL BE A PROJECT THAT
WILL STAND THE TEST OF TIME FOR
THE NEXT CENTURY OR BEYOND- TO
PROTECT. THE WATER SUPPLY AS
WELL AS OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT
LIVE- ALONG THE FLOOD PLAIN. OF
THE OF THE RESERVOIR AND THE
DAM. AND SO WITH THAT I WOULD.
LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN THANK. A
SUMMER REVERSED AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN ASK EVERYONE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE SAME ORDER
MICROPHONES UP- IS THERE A
MOTION TO MOVE THIS ITEM
FORWARD. MUCH OF THIS REPORT
CHOOSE OUR SECOND. IN WOMEN'S
RUBIO WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SURE
I JUST YOU KNOW- REALLY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
KALRA AND- I HIT THE YOU KNOW
POINTS HE MADE THIS IS A BILL
THAT WE HAVE DONE EXTENSIVE
WORK WITH WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
WITH- THE COMMITTEES HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY WE HAVE AMENDED
THE BILL SEVERAL TIMES WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE TO A
POINT TO NOT DO ANYTHING SO
REALLY- APPRECIATE SUPPORT AND
RESPECT WE ASK WHEN I BOUGHT.
THE COMMISSION CHECK THANK YOU
THE MEASURE AS A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THERE WAS A SECOND TO
THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA I'VE- EDUARDO
GARCIA HI MEGAN DALY. MAKING
DALY AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW HI
FLORA FLORA I CHIU. CHIU I
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA. GLORIA GLORIA HI KALRA.
KALRA I LEVINE LEVINE- MATHIS.
MATHIS BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA
RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I WOULD.
WOOD THE VOTE IS THIRTEEN TWO
ZERO. NEXT WILL HELP ITEM
ELEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
SIX FROM OUR CHAIR. SHARE AT
THE PRESENT AB TWO SEVEN THREE
SIX- THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
GIVE STATE OVERSIGHT OVER ANY
HYDRO ELECTRIC ENERGY STORAGE
PROJECT WITHIN TWENTY MILES OF
DR THREE NATIONAL PARK THE
ACCOMPLISHES THE TASK BY
REQUIRING PERSON SYSTEM IN A
MULTITUDE OF DATA AND REPORTS
INCLUDING GROUNDWATER
MONITORING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS THE STATE WATER BOARD.
THE NATIONAL PARK IS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND NATURAL
TREASURE TO THE STATE AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY TO MY DISTRICT.
FIFTY SIX ASSEMBLY DISTRICT OF
THE SENATE HEALTH FORMULA. HIS
MIND TEND TO DEVELOP A CREATIVE
APPROACH FOR THE STATE O
MONITOR AND IF NEEDED AND FORCE
AGAINST THE PROJECT. IF IT WAS
FOUND TO BE HEARD IN THE
ENVIRONMENT. THE BILL MEET THAT
GOAL BY CREATING MEDICATION FUN
TO GO DIRECTLY TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND RESTORATION THE
PARK. I DO WANT TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT- THE
OPPOSITION IS BROUGHT DIRECTLY
TO MY ATTENTION- AND ONE IS
THAT- THIS BILL. IS NOT WILL
NOT- IT BECOME A PROCUREMENT
BILL FOR ANY PROJECT- NOT THIS
VEHICLE- OR ANY OTHER VEHICLE
THAT I MAY BE WORKING ON. IN
THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I WON'T BE VERY
CLEAR WITH MY PUT MY MASK DOWN
LET EVERYONE KNOW THAT- SO THAT
YOU CAN SEE THIS YEAR'S NIS
BEHIND THAT STATEMENT. I ALSO
WANT TO JUST THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THE BILL CONTAINS ABSOLUTELY NO
LANGUAGE. ABOUT THE PROJECT AND
THE PROJECT INCREASING. ANY
ENERGY COSTS AND YOU'LL HEAR
SOME OF THAT BECAUSE I WAS.
DIRECTLY TOLD BY. MEMBERS OF
THE OPPOSITION- ABOUT THIS BILL
AS WELL. THIS BILL ABSOLUTELY-
SIMPLE V. SIMPLY ADDRESSES
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS. BY
BOISE IMPOSING MEANING FOR
STATE LEVEL SANCTIONS FOR ANY
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH GROUND
WATER. USE THRESHOLDS MEMBERS.
OF THIS COMMITTEE I REPRESENT
AN ECONOMICALLY UNDERSERVED
AREA. THAT CAN RESOURCE IS
EXPERIENCING SOME OF THE
HIGHEST POVERTY RATES. STEMMING
FROM OVERALL HONOR INVESTMENT.%
COMPARED TO OTHER PARTS OF OUR
STATE JUST TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE.
IMPAIR ACCOUNT IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF OUR DISTRICT- ON A
REALLY GOOD DAY. AS 20%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. IS THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY- WHAT IT THIS
BILL INTENDS TO HAVE AN EFFECT
ON. DOES NOT LIVE THAT FAR
BEHIND. SO NOW PUT IT INTO
CONTEXT DURING THIS- CLUB IN
NINETEEN. ECONOMIC RECESSION.
AND WE CAN EXPECT THOSE NUMBERS
TO PROBABLY STOP. THE HARSH
ECONOMIC REALITIES IN THE NEED
TO CREATE JOBS. THE EXISTING IN
OUR AREA INCLUDING VERY THIS
PANDEMIC- THE CIRCUMSTANCES
HAVE INTENSIFIED AS UP THE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS WILL
CONTINUE TO RISE. FOR THESE
REASONS THERE'S A LOT OF LOCAL
SUPPORT FOR THE PROJECT THAT
WILL BRING ABOUT EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AS ECONOMIC
REVITALIZATION IS MORE
IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER BUT LET
ME AGAIN BE VERY CLEAR. THIS
BILL. IS ABOUT BRINGING FOLKS
TOGETHER TO BUILD A SOLUTION
THAT HELPS OUR ECONOMY. AND
PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
THAT'STHE FOCUS THAT I WANT TO
ENSURE THIS BILL ACCOMPLISHES
PROTECTING OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
FINDING A CREATIVE WAY FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO HAVE
SOME OVERSIGHT AND POTENTIALLY
ENFORCEMENT IF IN FACT THIS WAS
TO EVER MOVE FORWARD INTO A
CONSTRUCTION PHASE WITH THAT
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES WOULD MEET JEFF
HARVEY WHO IS AN ENGINEER
HARPER CONSULTING GROUP AND
WATER EXPERT AND THE COACHELLA
VALLEY RESIDENTS. AND SCOTT LEX
REPRESENTING NINETY DOUBLE. SO
FIRST WE'LL HEAR FROM JEFFREY
HARVEY. A GOOD AFTERNOON GERMAN
GARCIA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
THIS TEST ONLY TODAY I AM JEFF
HARDY IMAGINE BUYER MENTAL
CONSULTANT RATHER THAN AN
ENGINEER- ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTIST FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS SPECIALIZING IN THE
CALIFORNIA AND FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW LAWS THE
VIN SEEK WORK AND ALL OF THE
RELATED- MARIO PERMITTING. THAT
PERTAINS TO WATER POWER MANY
PROJECTS AND A PHD FROM UCLA
SPECIALIZING WATER RESOURCES
NATURAL RESOURCES MANAGEMENT
ERROR ENVIRONMENT WHILE AND
POLICY. I HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH
LARGE SCALE PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
THOSE IN THE DESERT REGION THE
CHUCKWALLA VALLEY. AND ALL
INVOLVING WATER ENERGY. I WAS
HIRED BY EVIL CHRISTY ENERGY IS
THE PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR
BARBARA PERMITTING. AND WORKED
ON THE PROJECT FOR NEEDING WITH
BURK AND ALL RELATED STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES TO COMPLETE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
REQUIREMENTS IN MITIGATION
PLANNING. AS MENTIONED I AM-
RESIDENT OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY AND A REGULAR VISITOR TO
JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK. I
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION AS IT
FOCUSES STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ATTENTION ON
GROUNDWATER USED FOR UNIQUE
PROJECT THAT DOES NOT OTHERWISE
HAVE STEEP JURISDICTION. THE
PROJECT WILL BE DEVELOPED
WITHIN EXISTING BROWNFIELD MINE
SITE WILL USE UTILIZE A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE GROUND WATER
FROM THE CHUCKWALLA VALLEY
AQUIFER. WATER IS USED TO FILL
THE LOWER MINE PIT IN HIS THEN
A WORKING FLUID. PUMPED UP FOR
TWO HUNDRED FEET HIGHER TO
ANOTHER MINE PIT FOR ENERGY
STORAGE AND RELEASED BACK TO
LOWER AS WAR FOR ENERGY
GENERATION PROVIDING UP TO
THIRTEEN HUNDRED MEGAWATTS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY STORAGE. IT IS
UNDERGONE OVER TEN YEARS AND
REMEMBER REVIEW INCLUDING A
FEDERALLY I. S. THE STATE
MARLIN PAPERWORK. AND A
FEDERAL. ENVIRONMENTAL
ASSESSMENT. INVOLVING SOME SIX
THREE DIFFERENT AGENCIES WITH.
EITHER DIRECT OR- RESPONSIBLY
TO SEE STATUS. TECHNICAL
ANALYSES OF THE POTENTIAL
EFFECTS ON BROWN WATER BEING
CONDUCTED BY ALL OF THOSE
AGENCIES WITH EXPERTISE IN
WATER. GROUND WATER IN RELATED
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT. THE ENERGY
STORED FACILITY WILL USE LESS
THAN NINETY THOUSAND ACRE FEET
OVER THE THIRTY FIVE YEAR LIFE
OF THE PROJECT THAT'S LESS THAN
1% OF THE WATER IN STORAGE IN
THE AQUIFER. IN CONTRAST THE
OLD MINING OPERATION USED TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
GROUND WATER BETWEEN NINETEEN
FORTY EIGHT AND NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. IN IN ADDITION POPPING
FOR YOUR NATION IN THE LATE
SEVENTIES TO THE EARLY EIGHTIES
TOLD ALMOST ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRE FEET. OVER A
PERIOD OF LESS THAN TEN YEARS
NO- ADVERSE EFFECTS OF HISTORIC
MINING AND AGRICULTURE WATER
USES TOTALING NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
WERE OBSERVED OR TO HAVE
OCCURRED EITHER AFFECTING THE
JOSHUA TREE NATIONAL PARK OR
THE COLORADO RIVER AQUEDUCT.
PROJECTS TOLL ROAD WATER USE
OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS LIKE THE
PROJECT IS LESS THAN ONE THIRD
OF YOUR STORE GROUND WATER USE.
EXTRACTED OVER A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME AND IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THAT IS THE
HISTORICAL RECORD. THAT FOR
USED TO LIMIT THE PROJECT WATER
YOU SEEN IN THE LICENSE. WATER
TABLE LIES- ABOUT A HUNDRED
EIGHTY FEET BELOW GROUND
SERVICE HAS NO CONNECTION
OVERLYING VEGETATION DOOR
HABITAT. AND IS NOT SUPPORTING
SPINGS IN THE SURROUNDING
MOUNTAIN AREAS THAT ARE MUCH
HIGHER ELEVATION. FOR GLAZERS
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE OXFORD
WATER QUALITY PROTECTION OUR
EXTENSIVE THE INCLUDE LEYVA
PROJECT MONITORING IT DOZENS OF
WILLS AROUND THE PROJECT
RESERVOIRS. AROUND THE WATER
TREATMENT SYSTEM EVAPORATION
PONDS AND THROUGHOUT THE
CHUCKWALLA VALLEY. FERGUS SAID
VERY SPECIFIC LIMITS ON
GROUNDWATER PUMPING BY
REQUIRING THE PROJECT TO SLOW
OR STOP PUMPING. IF SPECIFIC
LEVELS OF GROUNDWATER DRAWDOWN
OCCURRED IN THOSE LIMITS THAT
THEY'VE SET ARE MUCH LESS THAN
WHAT OCCURRED WITH THE STORE
POPPING IN AND DRAW DOWN. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
GIVES THE STATE AN ACTIVE ROLE
MONITORING EFFECTUALLY OCTOBER
AND MAKING ADJUSTMENTS TO
POPPING RATES OR PUBLICATIONS
OR TO SEIZE PUMPING. IF THE
WATER TABLE REACHES SPECIAL
LEVELS. THAT'S THE IN MY
TESTIMONY HAPPY ANSWERING
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
THE SCOTT WATCH. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS GOT WET
YOUR BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PIPE TRADES COUNCIL THE
STATUS IS SEASONAL ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS AND THE CAL- THE
CONCERT ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
YOU FIRST AND FOREMOST I JUST
LIKE TO THANK THE SERGEANTS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND ALL THE
MEMBERS. FOR BEING HERE DURING
THESE TRYING TIMES IN DOING THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS IT'S MUCH
APPRECIATED MY MEMBERS ASKED ME
TO BE HERE TODAY BECAUSE FOR
OVER A DECADE. THEY HAVE WORKED
TO GET THIS PROJECT APPROVED
NOT JUST MY MEMBERS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BUT THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THIS JOB
THIS PROJECT CREATE OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND JOBS OVER
THREE YEARS IN AN AREA WHERE
TODAY WE HAVE 40% UNEMPLOYMENT
IN THE TRADES BUT WHAT DO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN
UNFAIRLY MALIGNED. AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL APPROVAL PROCESS
HAS BEEN GROSSLY. THIS
REPRESENTED BY THE OPPOSITION.
IT HAS BEEN IT HAS BEEN ARGUED
BY THE OPPOSITION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DID NOT PLAY A ROLE
IN THE PERMITTING OF THIS FRONT
OF THIS PROJECT WHEN IN FACT
THE STATE WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD IN CONSULTATION WITH FISH
AND WILDLIFE. SUBMITTED A
REQUEST FOR THIRTY CONDITIONS
ON THE FOR PERMITS FOR THIS
PROJECT. AND FOR APPROVED
TWENTY NINE OF THE US. THE ONE
THAT WASN'T APPROVED WASN'T
APPROVED BECAUSE THEY HAD TO DO
WITH PRIVATE SMALL WELLS AND
THOSE ISSUES GOT RESOLVED
OUTSIDE OF THE FOR PROCESS TO
IS RENDERED UNNECESSARY. SO
CALIFORNIA GOT VIRTUALLY EVERY
SINGLE CONDITION THAT IT
REQUESTED. THIS INCLUDES
EXHAUSTIVE MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS. IN COMPREHENSIVE
ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENTS. THIS PROCESS WAS
THOROUGH IT INVOLVE THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY FOR OVER MORE THAN A
DECADE. I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU
THAT THE OPPOSITION IS OPPOSING
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THEIR
DISTASTE FOR THE PROJECT ITSELF
AND NOT FOR THE MERITS OF THIS
LEGISLATION. GIVEN THE TRYING
TIMES THAT WE ARE ALL LIVING
THROUGH TODAY. I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THIS INTELLECTUAL
DISHONESTY. IN LEGISLATIVE
GAMESMANSHIP NEEDS TO BE
REJECTED BY SUPPORTING THIS
BILL AND PASSING IT OUT WE
REGION OF A THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANY MORE IN ROOM
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY CALLS
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX. THANK
YOU AS A REMINDER IF YOU ARE IN
FAVOR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
WILL GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI AND YOU
CAN DOLLARS FROM SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE ZERO FIVE
WITHIN AT THE BORDER THE BILL
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS MARKET
YREKA RICHET- CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL OUT WE ARE THE
NEAREST NEIGHBOR KID THIS
PROJECT WE FEEL ABOUT IT WOULD
BE A GREAT GREAT PROJECT TO GO
FORWARD WITH. AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE ARE THEY HAVE BEEN A
LONG TIME REVEALING THEIR AND
DOING ALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS IS NECESSARY TO MAKE
MAKE IT SAFE AND WORKABLE AND
WE DO NEED THIS KIND OF
EMPLOYMENT IN OUR AREA. I URGE
A YES VOTE. THANK YOU WILL GO
TO LINE ONE ALL ONE ONE HUNDRED
ONE. HI THIS IS NOT THE LEGAL
LARGER A TRIP YET THE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I URGE
EVERYONE TO VOTE YES. ON A
PICNIC THEM THIRTY FIFTH. THANK
YOU LINE ONE OH EIGHT ONE
HUNDRED EIGHT ALONE IS A. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ALISON RAINY ON BEHALF OF IBEW
LOCAL EIGHTEEN HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU LINE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD- YOU'D
GET AFTERNOON THIS IS MAYOR
STEVEN HERNANDEZ CITY OF
COACHELLA- CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWO SEVEN THREE SIX
WE'RE GONNA NEED THIS PROJECT.
THANK YOU LINE WON ALL FOUR ONE
HUNDRED FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IS MIKE MONICA ON BEHALF OF
IBEW LOCAL ELEVEN LOS ANGELES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE OF SIX ONE HUNDRED SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THAT THE
COLOR WALKING IN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BY TRADE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVEN THREE
SIX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOUR
NEXT DEADLINE ONE OWN NINE ONE
HUNDRED NINE. YES GOOD MORNING
THIS IS SERGIO CARRANZA- ON
BEHALF OF. THE NEW SERIES THREE
I AM CALLING ON THE BOARD TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX. AND
THESE OF THE TROUBLING TIMES IT
IS DEFINITELY TIME TO START
SUPPORTING LOCAL INITIATIVES
AND JOB CREATION SO WE CAN BE
OF MORE SUSTAINABLE AND HELP
YOU ARE LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
BECAUSE- THANK YOU LINE ONE OF
THREE. ONE HUNDRED THREE. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GERRY
GARDNER- I SERVED AS AN ELECTED
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN THE CITY
OF DESERT HOT SPRINGS IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY I'M ALSO THE
VICE CHAIR. OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY I
LOVE OUR DESERT HERE
PARTICULARLY JOSHUA TREE
NATIONAL PARK AND I WANT TO
COMMEND THE CHAIR OF THE OFF
REAL BILL PORTANTINO YOU WORK
TO PROTECT YOU OUGHT TO JUST
YOUR NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. TERM LINE
ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON GREG CERVANTES WITH
THE NATIVE GENERATIONS GROUP WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE NINETY EIGHT
NINE EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS TO PROVIDE THEIR VICTOR
VALUE PER RED RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OR DISTRICT FORMER SAID
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. CALLED SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX
COMMENDED CHAIR AND FOR ALL THE
POINTS THAT WERE MENTIONED
BEFORE ME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU LINE ONE ONE TWO ONE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DANA READ I MAYOR PRO
TEM OF THE CITY OF INDIAN WELLS
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE ONE FOURTEEN A
ONE ONE FOUR. HI THIS IS BOB
RIGHT WITH THE EAST VALLEY
COALITION ON EASTER COULD SHELL
OF ALLEY. A BUSINESS ALLIANCE-
WE'RE CALLING IN TO- LIKE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU NORTHERN
ALLIANCE IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE WITH
US IN PERSON FIRST WE'LL HEAR
FROM ME NEIL DOES HE FROM THE
NATIONAL PARKS CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION. GOOD MORNING I
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THAT COMMITTEE
NEIL TO SIDE WITH THE NATIONAL
PARKS CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
WELL. I KNOW THE AUTHOR CARES
ABOUT JOSHUA TREE- BUT THIS
BILL ANALYSIS MAKES PAINFULLY
CLEAR THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL AND THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION LAST. MAKES
PAINFULLY CLEAR THAT THIS IS
NOT AN ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
BILL NOW FIRST THE BILL CAN'T
PROVIDE THE STATE WITH
AUTHORITY OVER THIS PROJECT YOU
TO FEDERAL LAW PREEMPTION SO
IT'S INOPERABLE SECOND DESPITE
THE FEDERAL LAW PREEMPTION. THE
BILL ACTUALLY AUTHORIZES
EAGLECREST THE PUMP MORE GROG
GROUND WATERED DOWN THE LIMITS
BY CREATING AN EXEMPTION. THIRD
DESPITE THE FEDERAL PREEMPTION
THE BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE
WEEPING ENCOURAGE YOU PERHAPS
TO ACTUALLY VIOLATE ITS TERMS
BY TREATING. EIGHT A PENALTY
SYSTEM THAT ACTUALLY LIMITS
WHAT THE STATE CURRENTLY HAS
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO CAP AT THE
STATE. AND FOR THE STATE THIS
THIS BILL WASTE MONEY BY
MANDATING THE STATE TAKE
ACTIONS THAT LIKE I SAID IN THE
BILL ANALYSIS THAT IT PREVENTS
IT FROM TAKING IT INVITES
COSTLY A LITIGATION. WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN THE RED IN THE
BILLIONS WHY WOULD WE BE
FORCING A STATE AGENCY TO DO
THINGS YOU CAN'T DO. INSULIN BE
VERY CLEAR. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY. WAS NEVER CONSULTED
ON THE SPELL. THAT CLAIMS TO BE
PROTECTING ONE OF OUR COUNTRY'S
NATURAL WONDERS EAGLECREST IS
NOT FOUND A BUYER FOR ITS THREE
BILLION DOLLAR PROJECT NUMBER
TWO DECADES BECAUSE UTILITIES
AND REGULATORS. HAVEN'T FOUND
IT TO BE NEEDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER THAT
WOULD OVERDRAFT GROUNDWATER AT
JOSHUA TREE. SO THAT'S WHY THE
COMPANY OF COMPASS LEGISLATURE
THREE TIMES NOW. ASKING FOR A
BAIL OUT IN THE MOST RECENT ONE
DYING LAST WEEK. SO I JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING I THINK WE NEED
TO BE CLEAR AND HONEST WITH
OURSELVES THAT THIS IS NOT. AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION BILL-
WE ASK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE ALL OF YOU EVERYONE
HERE BACK IN HERE WE ARE ALL
EQUAL OWNERS OF JOSHUA TREE
NATIONAL PARK. IF WE'RE GONNA
BE WORKING TOWARDS ITS
PROTECTION. LET THEM ALL THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. NEXT IS CHANCE MUCH
IN JONES. MADAM CHAIR AND THE
GERMAN GARCIA ON JANICE MONEY
JONES WITH THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCER- MASS TODAY
LIKE ZORRO- BUT REPRESENTED A
BROAD COALITION OF INDUSTRIAL-
AGRICULTURAL- RAPIER GROUPS AS
WELL AS WELL AS MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS ALL OPPOSING SPECIAL
LEGISLATIVE TREATMENT FOR THE
EAGLE MOUNTAIN PUMPED STORAGE
PLANT- THE SUBSTANTIVE
LANGUAGE- OF THIS BILL THAT
SEEMS TO BE. LIMITED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP THAT
CRITERIA THAT WE UNDERSTAND
IT'S BEEN COPIED ON THE FORK
LICENSE OF FOR- THE EAGLE
MOUNTAIN A PROJECT AND- WE WANT
TO BE SURE THAT- THE- THAT THE
THAT THIS PLANT THAT THAT THIS-
LEGISLATION DOES NOT TURN INTO
SOMETHING ELSE. GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THIS PLAN IS NOT A GIVEN
THERE'S NOTHING THAT SAYS IT'S
GONNA GET BUILT THE- SORT OF
URGENCY OF IS BILL- IS
SOMEWHAT CURIOUS I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR OF FOR
BASICALLY A KNOWLEDGE AND THAT
HE WILL NOT GUT AND AMEND THIS
BILL TO TURN IT INTO A
PROCUREMENT BILL. FOR THIS
PROJECT- AND- WE ARE CONCERNS I
HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED HERE-
BASED ON THE FINDINGS THAT WERE
FIND BUT WE ARE NOT THAT TO
SUPPORT THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
BILL SPECIFICALLY OF FINDINGS A
AND B. WHICH WATER FAR BEYOND
PROTECTION OF BROWN WATER
RESOURCES AND WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO FOR THE GROUND WATER
RESOURCE THIS. WINTER WHAT
HERE'S THE EIGHTY HAS HAD A
TIME FINDING A BY WERE HELPFUL
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
HAVE HAD FOR. LEGISLATIVE
ATTEMPTS- TO BE WE SUPPORT-
EAGLE MOUNTAIN- IS ESTIMATED
THAT SO THIS IS WHAT BILLION.
ALL THREE. WOULD HAVE. THE COST
OF THE PLANTS WE ENDED. SO
STRAIGHT AT FOR. WHICH WILL BE
PAID STATE WIDE ALL YOUR CAN.
pOPPOSITE TO THIS BIASED. GROUP
OF MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ENVIRONMENTALISTS DOSES OF US
WHO BELIEVE IN COMPETITIVE
RENEWABLES- AND RAPIER GROUPS-
AND SO IT'S FOR THESE REASONS
THAT- WE- ARE ARE BASICALLY
ASKING TODAY- FOR A NO VOTE ON
THIS. AND AGAIN ONE OF THE
KNOWLEDGE AND THINK THE- YOU
OFFER FOR A KNOWLEDGE AND HE
WILL NOT I GOT AN AMEND THIS
BILL. BUT IN ADDITION WE WOULD
ASK THAT- IS- SPECIFICALLY
DECORATIONS THAT A AND B.
LIMITED AT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND SUGGEST THAT THIS. BILL IS
SOMEHOW WE GOT THE- APPROVAL OF.
LEGISLATURE WE DON'T THINK THIS
IS THE CASE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BY THE WAY THIS BILL IS BEFORE
THE PEACOCK BUT THE BILL IS
NOT. THE CALIFORNIA. PUMP
STORAGE AS PART OF THE PLANNING
AND PROCUREMENT PROCESS THAT'S
GOING ON NOW SO THE PROPONENTS
ACTUALLY WANT THIS PROJECT
BILL. THEY NEED TO PARTICIPATE
IN THAT PROCESS AND COMPETE
WITH EVERYBODY ELSE FAIR AND
SQUARE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. SCENE NINE
MISTER MODERATOR RE PLEASE OPEN
UP THE PHONES IN OPPOSITION FOR
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX. WE
DO HAVE LINE ONE HUNDRED IF
THERE ARE OTHERS PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NINE ONE ZERO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WARREN
COLUMN WITH HERE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. BUT ALSO GONNA
DIRECTOR OPPOSITION FOR THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATION.
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. MOHAVE
DESERT LAND TRUST. MORONGO
BASIN CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURED IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF FOOD PRODUCERS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCIES.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POWER AUTHORITY LARGE SCALE
SOLAR ASSOCIATION. SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION FIGHTERS
STORE PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP. CALIFORNIA HARDER POWER
REFORM COALITION. COALITION TO
PROTECT AMERICA'S NATIONAL
PARKS. CALIFORNIA SPORTFISHING
PROTECTION ALLIANCE. BASIN AND
RANGE WATCH WESTERN WATERSHEDS
PROJECT. CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. NATIVE AMERICAN LAND
CONSERVANCY. THAT VOICE
FOUNDATION. CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY AND ALEX POWER.
THANK YOU IN LINE ONE SIXTEEN
ONE ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVE ON THAT LINE DISCONNECTED
ONE OH SEVEN ONE HUNDRED SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. 99% ON
BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION WE
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR ITS
COMMITMENT TODAY BUT MY- OPPOSE
THE BILL AT THE TIME. MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
CALLS IN THE QUEUE. WHEN YOU
MAY CONTINUE. A WHEN MAKING TO.
SO ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS WITH
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. THIS
KALRA. I THINK THANK YOU AND I
DON'T WANT TO THANK ARE CHAIR-
GOOD CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL
AND- I APPRECIATE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- VERY MUCH AND
I APPRECIATE- THE CHALLENGE OF-
HAVING A POTENTIAL PROJECT IN-
IS DISTRICT IN TRYING TO
BALANCE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
NEEDS AND SO I CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT I'D NOT TOO LONG
AGO TO SPOKE ON A PROJECT SORT
OF LIKE MY DISTRICT AND SO I
DON'T- WOULD WOULD NEVER. SPEAK
NEGATIVE TO SOMEONE THAT'S
TRYING TO DO WHAT THEY CAN FOR
THEIR DISTRICT I ALSO- I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THE I HAVE
A PRIORITY BILL MAYBE THIRTY
THIRTY WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
PROTECT PRECIOUS LAND SIMILAR
TO THAT OF THAT SURROUNDS
JOSHUA TREE AND SO I APPRECIATE
UP MISTER SHARES OPENING THAT
THE IS NOT THE INTENTION FOR
THIS TO BECOME A PROCUREMENT OR
ENERGY THE CURRENT TIE BILL BUT
TO PUT FORTH SOME. FORM OF A
SET OF GUIDELINES REGARDING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION. THE
FOR A COUPLE OF THE QUESTIONS
OF WELL WHAT ONE OF THE I GUESS
COMMON FOOD AND WE CAN TALK
FURTHER ABOUT THE SOUNDS GOOD
TO THE HEARING IT IS IN REGARDS
TO- WHETHER THE BILL IS REALLY
NECESSARY- GIVEN THAT THERE'S
FEDERAL GUIDELINES IN PLACE-
AND SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU IT
AND I'LL JUST ASK A QUESTION
YOU CAN COMMON AS YOU SEE FIT-
WHAT WHETHER THE BILL GIVES. IN
AND WORKING WITH THE WATER
BORDER OR THE SOME OF THE-
GUIDELINES FOR BY THE WATER
BOARD. IS ACTUALLY GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO DO. THE SAME MORE OR
LESS THAN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN TERMS OF.
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT IN
TERMS THIS PROJECT BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING THAT. I KNOW THAT IS
A CONCERN TO YOU AND MANY
OTHERS IS MAKING SURE THAT WE
STILL. RETAIN SOME AUTHORITY-
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY THAN
WHAT. IF ANYTHING THE BILL DOES
IN THAT REGARD. AND THE OTHER-
ASPECT OF IT IS. IN THE IN
FINDINGS ONE A ONE BEGIN AGAIN
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
HAPPEN. DISCUSS HERE RIGHT NOW
WE CAN DISCUSS. SUBSEQUENT TO
THIS HEARING ARE THERE ARE
REFERENCES- THAT GO BEYOND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
REGARDING- THE NEED FOR THE
PROJECT- AND SO. THAT'S
SOMETHING I HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT. IN
TERMS OF ENSURING THAT- IF IT'S
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
THAT IS THE KEY. COMPONENTS TO
THIS PARTICULAR SOLUTION THAT
I'M ORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU- AS WELL AS THE- THAT
PROPONENTS AND OPPOSITION. MAKE
SURE THAT- WE CAN TRY TO BRING
OF ONE OF THE TABLE WHICH I
KNOW THAT YOU'VE INDICATED TO
ME. PERSONALLY OF IS A GOAL OF
YOURS AND CERTAINLY OF MINE AS
WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE. IS A LEASE
COMMUNICATING WITH EACH OTHER.
AS TO WHAT IS IT WHAT IS NEEDED
TO PROTECT. THE ENVIRONMENT AND
PROTECT THIS IMPORTANT NATIONAL
AND STATE RESOURCE AND SO- I-
YOUR COMMITMENT AND- LOOK FOR
TO WITH YOU MORE. FOLLOW
THROUGH AND FOR THAT AS- WELL
FORWARD. THAT IT. HOLDS TO THE
GOALS THAT. SEEMS TO CREATE A
NEW REGION I STANDARDS OF FOUR
OF. FOR REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAVE.
WITH ANY POTENTIAL PROJECT ARE.
THAT THEY'D PROTECTION JOSHUA
TREE THE SURROUNDING AREA IS
PARAMOUNT. THANK YOU. MR LIVE.
AT THE YOU MADAM ICEI DO HAVE
A FOR THE THAT THAT HAD THE
EXPERTISE ON THE- THE
REMEDIATION ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL APPLICATIONS.
SPECIFICALLY. THANK YOU ANSWER
IF YOU COULD JUST PLEASE RE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF JEFF HARDY
YOU ADDRESSED ENERGY AND
NEXTERA ENERGY RESOURCES THANK
YOU. I DON'T WANT TO LEAD YOU
THROUGH A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
THAT YOU KNOWING WHAT MY
CONCERNS ARE SO I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT MY CONCERNS ARE AND THEN
YOU EVEN. MAYBE A BETTER PLACE
TO ADDRESS THEM- WE HAD A
WITNESS IN TESTIMONY- ACTUALLY
OPPOSED TO A PRIOR BILL TODAY
IS HE MARTIN FROM THIS YEAR
FIND- IS- I'D MET ON A TRIP TO
EMPIRE MINDS- STATE PARK- IN
THIS YEAR NEVADA AS- ON A TRIP-
A FEW YEARS AGO. WHERE ALONG
THE WAY ON THAT TRIP WE WERE
REALLY WE WERE ABLE TO DETECT
BY SIGHT LEAD- THAT HAD
CONTAMINATED- THE FOOTHILLS
SINCE MINING OPERATIONS MANY
YEARS AGO. AND SO- WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MINES REMEDIATION
OF THEM THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT AND I WANTED TO HEAR
FROM YOU THE STAFF CAN THE
MESSAGE THE THING IS THAT THAT
BETTER TAKE PLACE NOW TODAY-
WITH ANY ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
AND CONTAMINATION FROM. AND I
DO WANT TO THROW YOU WHAT I
THINK IS A SOFTBALL OF WHAT
FURTHER STEPS ARE YOU GOING TO
DO IF NECESSARY- IF THIS
PROJECT GOES FORWARD THAT WOULD
REMEDIATE ANY CONTAMINATION ARE
POISONOUS ACTIVITY THAT DID. IN
FACT OCCUR. I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION EIGHT IS AN ISSUE THAT
WAS OF PRIMARY CONCERN TO FORK
INTO THE STATE WATER BOARD- THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF ACID MINE
DRAINAGE. WE DON'T HAVE LEAD
THIS IS NOT A WAS AN IRON ORE
MINE AND- WE HAVE A FEW
CHEMICAL OF A PC GEOCHEMISTRY
OVER FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
DATA AND INFORMATION AS YOU CAN
YES. AS THE MINING ACOSTA S. IN
YEAH SO WHAT THE IS A ONE. MY
UNDERSTOOD DID YOU AS WELL MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT HI RATE
IS. THE BIGGEST ISSUE ROAD DESK.
AND DRAINAGE AND THAT THE MINE
ADORING. HAVE A HIGH OF IRATE
THIS MINE HAS A LOW OF PIRATE.
AND HE SAID THAT WE DO HAVE
REQUIRE. IN THE FIRST LICENSE
FOR IT WHAT WE CALL A PICKET
FENCE OF WILDER SO THERE'S A
WHOLE SERIES OF WILLS THE
RELOCATED DOWNSLOPE FROM EACH
OF THE RESERVOIRS. AND THEY ARE
REQUIRED DIG MONTHLY SAMPLES
AND TEST FOR WATER QUALITY FROM
ANY SEEPAGE LOSSES. AND THEN TO
IF THEY'RE WE DETECT THAT THERE
ARE WE PUMP THAT WATER OUT. OR
WE TREAT THAT- TREATMENT- YOU
LOOK TO THE RIGHT VERSUS MOST
TREATMENT SYSTEM ALREADY THAT
IS ALREADY PART OF THE PROJECT.
AND THAT'S DESIGNED TO MAINTAIN
THE WATER QUALITY IN THE
RESERVOIRS AT THE LEVEL OF THE
WATER QUALITY THAT DIDN'T
THAT'S PUT INTO THE RESERVOIRS.
WERE ALSO REQUIRED TO LINE
RESERVOIRS WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY AN EIGHT FOOT
LININGS VERY SUMMER DONE FOR
LANDFILL THAT INCLUDES CLAY AND
YOU FABRIC LINERS AND THE LOWER
RESERVOIR WILL ALSO INCLUDE A-
ROLLER COMPACTED CONCRETE DAM.
ON ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE EAST
MOST PORTION WHICH IS ACTUALLY
IN CONTACT WITH ALLUVIUM RATHER
THAN BEDROCK IN THE BEDROCK
AREAS- SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
TREATMENT THE VETERAN FINAL
ENGINEERING. BUT IS SUBJECT TO
THE RIVER OVER OF THE REVIEW
APPROVAL IT IS INTENDED
SPECIFICALLY. REDUCE THOSE
LOSSES OF THE POTENTIAL. FOR
THAT KIND OF REACH. I THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU. YEAH I I'M
GOING TO. BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL MISTER CHAIR HI APPRECIATE
YOU PUTTING FORWARD- WHAT I SEE
ON ITS FACE IS AN ATTEMPT TO
STRENGTHEN ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS IT'S INTERESTING
THAT YOUR YOUR MOTIVES HERE
INTENTIONS ARE RE REALLY BEING.
CALLED OUT HERE AND THAT'S AN
UNCOMFORTABLE PLACE FOR ANY OF
US TO BE. AND YOU HAVE- YOU
HAVE BEEN A SUPPORTER OF THIS
PROJECT BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOU CAN'T ALSO BE A
SUPPORTER OF OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. I DON'T I DON'T
THINK THOSE TWO HAVE TO BE
SEPARATE AND I THINK THAT
YOU'VE DEMONSTRATED INCREDIBLE
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP IN
YOUR TIME HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. I THINK THAT THOSE
DUAL MOTIVES CAN EXIST TOGETHER
TO SUPPORT A PROJECT BUT ALSO
TO SAY. WE HAVE SHARED
ENVIRONMENTAL VALUES AND WE
WANT TO PUT THEM FORWARD IT
REMINDED ME. WHEN I FIRST HEARD
ABOUT THIS BILL OF- CENTER
ATKINS SP ONE LAST YEAR WHICH-
I SUPPORTED. WAS GOING TO HOLD-
STATE STANDARDS AS HIGH AS
PRIOR FEDERAL STANDARDS- THE
GOVERNOR HAD VETO THAT BILL-
BECAUSE A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
AND I THINK THAT THOSE CONCERNS
ALSO AT THE SPECIFIC CONCERNS
BUT CONCERNS ABOUT SOME
CONFLICTS. STILL HOVER AROUND
THIS BILL AS WELL. BUT THAT
YOU'RE YOU'RE APPROACHING IT
FROM A DIFFERENT ANGLE. YOUR
YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE YOU'RE
PROVIDING A TEST IF YOU WILL OF
HOW CAN THE STATE. PUT FORWARD
I IT'S ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS
IN A WAY THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE
SO BEFORE ON A FEDERALLY
APPROVED PROJECT. AND I THINK
THAT THIS IS A TEST THAT'S
WORTHY OF PUTTING FORWARD. AND
THAT WE ALSO HAVE TO TRUST YOU
OUR COLLEAGUE IN YOUR MOTIVES
FOR WHY YOU'RE DOING THIS SO I
THINK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DECLARED
AS YOU BEGAN YOUR PRESENTATION-
BUT ALSO FOR THIS NOVEL
APPROACH. OF PUTTING FORWARD
OUR VALUES IN THE FACE OF- AT
AN UNCERTAIN FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU. I SEE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE. I THANK
YOU WHAT MADE MY SHARE TAKE YOU
OFF COLLEAGUES. LEVINE FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. THAT IS EXACTLY
CORRECT- WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO
AS THEY WOULD SAY THREAD THE
NEEDLE. ON WHAT IS A VERY
SENSITIVE ISSUE RELATED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN RAISED. OVER THE COURSE OF
THE DIALOGUE ABOUT THIS
PROJECT. WHERE I TAKEN THOSE
CONCERNS AND I. ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS THEM. AND EXPLORE AS I
USED TO WORK CREATIVE EARLIER
WAYS. TO HAVE THE STATE. HAS A
MENTAL SOME ADDITIONAL INPUT AS
IT WAS SAID EARLIER TWENTY NINE
OF THIRTY. COMMENTS SEVEN GIVEN
TO BURKE WITH DOCTOR MAYBE
THERE'S- TWENTY NINE MORE. T
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO PUT FORWARD
I DON'T KNOW BUT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE. ATTEMPTING TO DO ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE. AND I
COULD BE IF. AND IN A LOOK AT
THE OP. YOU KNOW THAT PUSHED ON
DECK OF MY INTEGRITY OR- YOU
KNOW MY COMMITMENT TO- THE WORK
ON THIS BILL. AND THAT IT BE
NOT MOVING INTO A DIFFERENT JOB
FORM OF DOWN THE ROAD. BUT I'M
NOT IN FACT MY BIGGEST CONCERN
IS. THAT I DIDN'T HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION THEIR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH ME. TO BE ABLE TO GET
TO A PLACE OF COMMON INTERESTS.
TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING JOSHUA TREE AND ANY
OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL ADVERSARIAL
AFFECTS THAT COULD HAPPEN IF A
PROJECT DOWN THE ROAD APPEARS I
APPRECIATE ARE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THEY TALK
ABOUT. THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO
REGION THE NEEDS THE JOBS I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT THAT'S NOT
THIS BILL. I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT- WHEN I STAND
CORRECTED WITH MR HARVEY'S
CREDENTIALS AND HIS BACKGROUND
AND EXPERTISE- I APPRECIATE HIM
WALKING US THROUGH ALL OF THE-
CONDITIONS ARE REGULATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT TO. THIS PROJECT
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. BUT
THAT'S NOT THIS BILL THIS BILL
IS ABOUT HOW CAN THE STATE PLAY
A GREATER ROLE. IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING THE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE I. MANY TIMES
APPEAR SACRAMENTO THE POLITICS
PLAY OUT QUITE DIFFERENTLY THAN
THE REALITIES ON THE GROUND.
AND IT WORKS ON ALL SPECTRUM
IT'S NOT JUST THE ENVIRONMENTAL
SIDE OR NOT JUST LABOR SIDE IT
WORKS ALL THE WAY AROUND TO
WHERE AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT'S THE PEOPLE ON THE GROUND
THE PEOPLE WHO CALLED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY. NON
LOCAL FOLKS THEY RECOGNIZE THE
HURT THAT'S HAPPENING TODAY AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE COMING
FORWARD AS IT RELATES TO THE
ECONOMY BUT THAT ARE ALSO
ENCOURAGING US TO TRY TO FIND A
BALANCE. IN ADDRESSING THE LONG
STANDING ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
TO THE ISSUE OUT THERE WITH
THIS PROJECT. AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS SOME SAY THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THIS BILL I'M ASKING
TODAY UP FOR A VOTE OF
CONFIDENCE AND NOT JUST A VOTER
CURTIS. I MET FOR WHAT. IN THE-
TO HELP BRING. FOLKS TO THE
TABLE TO ACTUALLY GET TO A
PLACE WE ARE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS. AS I MENTIONED
MY BIGGEST CONCERN ISN'T THAT
THEIR QUESTIONING MY ANTENNA MY
INTEGRITY IT'S THE FACT THAT I
HEARD ZERO COMMENTS FROM THE
OPPOSITION. THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO COME FORWARD AND
HELP US GET TO A BETTER PLACE
THAT'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN I'M
ASKING FOR YOUR VOTE. AGAIN NOT
AS A COURTESY BUT MORE AS A
COMMITMENT TO HELP US GET TO A
BETTER PLACE TO ADDRESSING
THOSE CONCERNS. AND MAKING SURE
THAT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
DURING THIS RECOVERY TIME
HAPPEN ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING MY AGENT.
THAT HASN'T 2520% UNEMPLOYMENT
ANY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU I HAVE A MOTION. CHOI
AND MATHIS. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA BY EDUARDO
GARCIA HI MEGHAN DALLY MEGHAN
DALLY I BIGELOW. BIGELOW I
FLORA FLORA HI YOU. TWO I
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA. KALRA HI LEVINE
LEVINE I MATHIS. MATHIS I
BLANCA RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS I WOULD. WOULD I
VOTERS FOURTEEN ZERO. THE MS
PRICE CHAIRED THANK YOU I THINK
WE HAVE A THE ROLE OPEN FOR A
COUPLE OF BILLS TO ADD ON A
MEMBERS WILL GO DOWN THE LIST I
HAVE THE SECRETARY WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR- YOU
COMMITMENT TWO AND A HALF HOURS
OR SO OVER TWO HOURS AND FORTY
FIVE MINUTES OF HOPE. HELP MAKE
RUN AS WELL AS POSSIBLE AND
ALSO JUST THANK EVERYONE WHO
TOOK THE TIME TO COVER THE FACE
WITH A MASK AS WE'VE BEEN ASKED
TO DO SO- WE KNOW THAT IT'S NOT
MANDATORY BUT CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT IS BEING HIGHLY
RECOMMENDED FOR EVERYONE SO I
CAN ALWAYS THAT THANK YOU AGAIN
EVERYONE- BUT THE SECRETARY WE
PLEASE GO DOWN THE LIST OF THE
AGENDA FOR ADULTS. CO THE UPS
MEMBERS. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I. WOULD WOULD
I THE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS FOURTEEN TO ZERO.
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
ITEM TEN A. B. TWO SIX NINE
THREE FOR MISTER BLOOM. THE
CHAIR VOTING I. FLORA. CHIU TWO
I. CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I. SALAS. VOTERS NINE TO
THREE. SO AT THIS TIME OF THE
WATER PARKS. OF.
CALL IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM TWELVE AB
THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE SURE
VOTING YES CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I. THE VOTE IS
FOURTEEN ZERO. WE'LL KEEP WILL
KEEP THE. I THINK WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR TWO MEMBERS
TO COME IN AT ON.
MY APOLOGIES
MISTER CHAIR IS THE MEDIAN
STILL GOING. MY APOLOGIES MISS
MODERATOR ARE YOU DONE
EXCELLENT JOB TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE WAITING TO-
CLOSE OUT THE ROLE ON A COUPLE
OF ITEMS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU FOR- YOUR
WORK GOOD THINGS OF RUN VERY
SMOOTHLY TODAY. THANK YOU. GET
OFF AND BY THANK YOU.
AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY THREE SALAS NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY AT THIS TIME WE ARE
GOING TO ADJOURN THE- WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR THURSDAY MAY
FOURTEENTH THANK YOU EVERYONE-
STAFF TO MODERATOR AND ALL
THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED. IN THE
DRUG.